If you tell me that my choices are a Marxist Leninist Tanky who
wants to end liberal democracy and anyone you can think of, do
you not think that it's a
>> Democrats don't give a about you? They would literally
shoot you in the head if it meant that they would be able to
secure additional electoral wins. That he like doesn't really
understand the stuff he talks about. >> Stop doing this,
bro. I am consistent. I literally said I would Minecraft myself
between Hassan. That's not what I'm That's not the inconsistency.
>> Is it Is it possible I could I could understand that?
Yeah. Is it reasonable?
>> We might jump right into some content here cuz we've
got I've got a lot on the docket and I do actually want to keep
it moving today. So, Pisco and Hutch, they end up talking about
this the Dems flowchart quite a bit. Are we all familiar with
the flowchart? The [__] the Dems flowchart where
it's like, did Dems do it? Okay. Could it have been done better?
Okay. something Dems suck. Dems suck. Every every OP every single
path in the flowchart leads to Dems suck. Republicans did something
bad, it's because Dems didn't fight hard enough. Republicans
did something bad and Dems have power. Democrats didn't fight
hard enough. Or it's basically just all the ways you can blame
the Democrats. And Hutch brings this up a lot. Says Hassan's
group does this a lot. Okay, just a little context for this whole
talk we're going to have
Now,
I could watch more of this. I'm not totally sure. I I do like
the title. He did debate with Hutch, the devil. I feel a little
bad for Pisco in that he he does talk to Hutch and Hutch
doesn't look good in the conversations. I don't know what Pisco
is supposed to do sometimes.
You know what I'm saying? Anyway, we keep going. >> No,
no, no. I'm like, somebody could be doing the the Dems's flowchart
logic >> because they genuinely believe in the principle
of the Dems's flowchart. Or somebody could be like Hassan who
was doing it in a malicious bad faith dishonest way when he said
when he says something like Gavin Newsome would kill a trans
I mean can we just dwell on that for a second bro? He said that
>> yeah I can forgive a little bit hyper >> to win.
>> He I can forgive a little bit of hyperbole. Okay, that's
fine. All right listen we put pepper on things. We're streamers.
It is what it is. But that is a really remarkable thing to say
that the Democrats would rather murder you. If they if they knew
that murdering you would get them more votes, they would murder
you. That is him saying that the Democratic Party as an institution
is Hutch. Hutch understands that the hyperbole is
that if they can throw an identity group under the bus, like
the hyperbole is is basically if they have to leave some identity
group or some interest group behind to secure an electoral win,
they will do that. Hutch literally advocates for this. That's
when Hutch says he'd vote for a segregationist in certain states.
That's why he says that, right?
Because it's not it's not adopting principles. It's basically
being super flexible in your principles and letting people in
like that who would take the rights away from certain people,
right? Like like Hutch is the guy who's saying, "Yeah, I don't
want to make it like, you know, you you shouldn't be persona
nonrada if you're a
That's that Hutch is the guy Hutch is the guy who's willing to
throw somebody under the bus,
right? That's that's literally his idea. That's that's the political
theory he has adopted and he wants.
And I don't think he literally hates trans people. That's not
what it means. It means you're willing to leave them behind.
By the way,
uh terrifying thing here. I actually agree with Hutch. Unfortunately,
you got to leave trans people behind. If Republicans are going
to spend hundreds of millions of dollars fighting against trans
people, you that's like that's like the Democrat version of giving
weapons to Ukraine. Okay. Yeah. It's like this is such an efficient
effective win for us if we just walk away from this issue. We
they just spent tons of their capital attacking an issue we've
walked away from entirely.
Like it's it's it's literally just you stack nothing but wins
there in in a purely realist sense that would be very smart.
Now, should you actually trans people behind? No, probably not.
Okay. No, you shouldn't. You should stand on principle. But I'm
just saying that
he should be unapologetic about it. If he if he does think this,
and he does, he should be unapologetic about it. evil to its
core. >> This is going to get me cancelled by Would you
Would you agree with that though? Would you agree with that?
Like he's saying that the Democratic Party is evil and dehumanizing
and they don't value the lives and safety of vulnerable people.
That's what he's saying. >> He's saying he's saying that
they're unprincipled and that that >> Oh, so uh Pisco is
just going to steal my whole flow then. Okay, good one. Pisco,
I actually do want to pull it up now. So, thank you for reminding
me of the tweet, Ry. Thank you. We've got this tweet which is
just explaining Hassan's position here. Okay. As a statement
to trans voters, Democrats don't care about you. They would literally
shoot you in the head if it meant it would secure the electoral
wins. You're yelling at one of the few people that does give
a about trans people in general. Okay, that's all you're doing.
Democrats don't give a about you. They would literally shoot
you in the head if it meant that they would be able to secure
additional electoral wins. Shut the [__] up. Yeah.
So
again, I do think that is hyperbole.
Obviously, I don't think Hassan literally believes that Gavin
Newsome would shoot somebody in the head. I think he is communicating
that they've signaled that they would leave trans people behind
in some way or another, right? And he he says the the reason
he believes that is because Gavin Newsome came out and said after
the election, well, you know, we shouldn't have run so hard on
trans issues. We got to drop some of this stuff, right?
And I I think by the way I think that's electorally smart. I
think you maybe have to think about doing that if you're Democrats
with trans is with trans issues specifically. They are very very
they cost you a ton and you don't gain a lot from them. Okay.
Now you can have the whole conversation over where you talk about
principles versus electoralism,
right? You can have that
Yeah. The transports thing is what I'm talking about on the Charlie
Kirk podcast. Yes. That's one of the signals I'm talking about.
Okay. Uh Camela, God, Kamla, sorry, didn't run on trans people
at all. That's the thing about it. Yes, but you have you do have
to counter signal. You you have to basically say no, that's true.
No, I don't believe that because she had previously had the most
progressive voting record in the Senate. She's from California.
There is not a trans bill that was proposed by the Dems that
she didn't support. Okay. So, so she needed to distance from
that. Yes. She needed to counter signal against herself. Okay.
And she didn't do that. Gavin stepped up, did that immediately
after the election because I'm pretty sure polling showed, hey,
you should have done this. Okay.
I'm pretty sure that's why Gavin went and did it
anyway.
Okay, keep going. Um, they follow wherever the wind blows. Um,
and there are a lot of people >> that necessarily means
that necessarily means that the Democratic Party don't care about
vulnerable people >> as a principled matter, right? like
they would they value their own, >> you know, professional
ambition and political ambition over >> it's all a lie.
It's all it's all a lie. It's all performative. All they care
about is rainbow flags and uh you know, performative corporate
advertising. And you know, they don't actually care about the
suffering in the way that I do. I, Hassan [__] and
in fact, how dare you accuse me, Hassan [__] of not
caring about trans people. Well, that was the other part of that
clip that I left out. But like >> So, can we address it?
>> The other part of it, too, which is like very Trumpy,
right? That's very Trumpy, >> Well, um, wait. Trumpy to
say that they don't care about you. The politicians don't care
about you.
>> Uh, Kla Harris could have just tried to have any vision
for the country. I feel
I feel like Kla Harris
uh when I think about that campaign, it was just like
we're real humans and we don't like Donald Trump. We're real
humans and we don't like Donald Trump. And
I get how you might think that running that way helps, but man,
also
dude, it's it's not even real humans. I I need Democrats to stop
with the goofy ass we're going to graft on positions. I feel
like every Democrat candidate once they get to the general right
now is a homunculus that's just got different body parts grafted
onto them. They're like a normal person who has some charisma
and could be good and then they start grafting positions on like
Tim Walls taking pictures of himself hunting and I'm just like
dude I don't like maybe you have hunted before but I don't think
this is a big part of your life and I I feel like you're kind
of playing into they all do this thing where they're like trying
to play up like oh we won't take away guns cuz Tim Walls has
a gun and it's like dude okay stop stop being weird goofy
scientific you horror experiments, okay? Please just run as people.
They're abominations, okay? With all these different positions
grafted on that don't really fit coherently together. It's just
goofy, man. No, it doesn't work when Tucker does it. No, no,
no, no. It doesn't work when Tucker does it. That cabin is the
biggest abomination I've ever seen. Okay, [__] off.
It works when Tucker does it. It works when Tucker does it because
everybody who watches Tucker has dementia. Okay. It does not
work for Tucker with normal human beings.
It doesn't. >> It's very Trumpy to frame it to frame it
in a way of uh they're not coming after me. They're coming after
you and I'm I'm in the way. And so all these people that are
coming down on me, Hassan [__] all these people that
are coming down on me, it's because their core is paid or they're
DC consultants and they're a part of a machine that would rather
murder you if it if they thought that it would get them votes.
I'm the guy. Don't question me. How dare you say that I don't
care about trans people? Cuz I would say I would vote for third
party. I'm Hassan [__] Have you seen me with my media
vest when I go on the streets, when I walks when I walk amongst
the people, you know, like it's that kind of framing, right?
It's very self- serving. It's very Trumpy. Yeah. >> Um
Yeah. To the extent that it's like leaning on notions of the
establishment don't care or swamp creature or whatever the [__]
I I mean, I guess that that's that's Trumpy. Um, and yeah, but
like I I just don't know that sentiment to me. They don't really
care about you. You know, politicians don't care about you. They
would [__] they suck the adrenal chronium out of
your skull if you could get them an extra vote. You remember
Hillary Clinton did the about face on gay marriage. Like a lot
of politicians are like this and they see which way the wind
is blowing and they change a dime.
>> Do you doubt that? Man,
there is a difference between like politicians shifting with
the political winds
in ways that
make perfect strategic sense and you know you would you argue
for example that it would be morally good
to take a you know let's just take Obama for example Obama in
>> the country had not moved at that point to majority
support for gay marriage >> and he ran on marriage between
being between a man and a woman. I think he was lying when he
said that. I think he did support gay marriage. And then when
he eventually switched, it was like kind of like right around
the time that the Supreme Court decision came in and it was right
around the time that the public shifted to majority support.
Hutch is just defending lying here. And it's like
uh I'm not going to say politicians can't lie about some like
fringe belief they have. But
I he's basically defending the abominations.
That's what he's defending right now for for gay marriage. Would
you argue that it is morally good to lie about a position like
that if it helps you win an election and therefore empowers you
to say for example appoint a Supreme Court justice who was one
of those votes to for O Burgerell?
>> I have to be convinced. I mean you're just presenting
me the you know harm >> abominations. Yeah. I'm starting
to get annoyed with like the politicians who believe things that
are like kind of incoherent or just like that when you're campaigning
you like have to show that you like a gun, you like own a gun,
you have to do all these things, check all these boxes. And I'm
just like I actually think we're getting out of the era of that.
I think like I I want somebody who who makes sense as a person.
I want like Bernie Sanders but 50. Okay. Somewhere in America,
there has to be Bernie Sanders but 50 years old. We're like the
stuff all fits together. Okay. >> Action trolley problem
again. And of course I'll I'll bite the bully that bullet that
sometimes. >> Yeah, the PC veneer thing. Yes, exactly.
It's like politically correct. You're like signaling to groups
that you're not going to take their rights away or something.
It's goofy as I hold on.
>> I have to be convinced. I mean, you're just presenting
me the, you know, harm reduction trolley problem again. And of
course I'll I'll bite the bully that bullet that sometimes lying
is justified. Um I would have to okay >> you know you know
the particular lie in the context of it uh matter. >> Hey
is Pisco wearing shades indoors cuz his eyes are red. >> He
literally says in this he says my eyes are really red right now.
>> No doubt
that's that's part of the critique though is I mean it's not
just in terms of signaling. It's in terms of what they're willing
to do. And um in some ways you >> already discussed though.
Hey hang on. We've already discussed what they're willing to
do bro. I mean they they have every single basically every single
blue state they are passing laws >> in
context but but again deal with the I know that he's a bad faith
piece of Hassan Hassan bad but if we are going to do the labor
of actually like dealing with the point as though he were good
faith good person whatever then we should just like address the
point the point isn't that now Democrats are doing literally
nothing the point is um that he's not a reliable ally in that
all it would take is a shift in public polling and all of a sudden,
you know, you can't count on them. That's the kind of uh critique
there. And by saying, well, now they're doing stuff, it's not
really addressing Hassan's point. And um yeah, I think that you
ought to I think you ought to take it on on uh Hutch is acting
like he's totally baffled. What my question is,
okay, I hate to say it. Hutch is like one of those covert but
not overt misogynists. All right. I I I'll say it because I don't
think anybody else will. This is just the exact conversation
he had with Straighter. Okay. Like precisely the conversation
he had with Straight Raid. And I feel like now he's going to
listen to Pisco and he's going to like hear some of this stuff.
Probably not still not going to internalize it, but like maybe
he'll actually answer some of the arguments
cuz this is the precise conversation he had with Straight Raid.
Like, hey, actually actually
if you have principles, the polling is like slightly irrelevant.
You can't just wait to support your principles until the polling's
there or else you don't really have principles. And it's like,
well, gay marriage was not something I could support until it
was popular.
It's like I Okay,
do you understand that like Republicans will take on UN Dude,
the tariffs are a great example. The tariffs are an example of
like, hey, we need manufacturing in our country for not only
national security reasons, but for like for the sake of our economy
not crashing if the global financial system takes a hit, right?
For us being able to build things and and do stuff ourselves.
There's like a whole bunch of reasons we should have a manufacturing
sector. How can we do that? Tariffs, right? And while I think
that the tariffs are super bad, the way they've implemented them
is awful. I think like slowly tariffing industries to get them
back on shore could have made a lot of sense,
but it would have been like wildly unpopular. All right.
Wildly, wildly unpopular.
And they did it anyway. They do a lot of stuff anyway. They do
a lot of stuff regardless of how popular it is and then they
tell you this is why it should be popular. Except with them they
don't even give you like the good reasons it should be popular.
They basically just lie to you. >> I don't know. It's it's
pretty crazy man >> it's strongest. Um and the one thing
you might say is well look >> dude Killinger Scott Bessant
had a plan. Scott Bessinger sorry not Scott Bessinger. I just
read your name as a part of it. Uh Scott Bessant had a plan for
doing this and Trump was just like nah [__] it. We
do it all at once. Nah [__] it everybody. [__]
all of you. It's crazy, man.
It's absolutely wild. >> Right now, it's unpopular
um to do certain things and they're still doing it. And so, you're
wrong, Hassan, because A, B, C, or D. And Gavin Newsome, you
know, did this, that, and the third. And that shows you that
you're actually wrong about it, uh, about what's going on there.
But I I don't think that like saying they don't really care about
us. Um, in some ways, like you embody that in terms of your,
um, I don't know, ruthless attitude towards electoralism. like
you're you're willing to say um you know if it help us win an
election like all right sorry abortion rights if I knew that
>> yeah Pisco is trying to slowly explain to Hutch hey
Hutch you I've already argued you already think you would trans
people in the head Hutch Hutch hey Hutch you literally believe
this already just so you know Hutch you actually already literally
believe this part about trans people in the head okay I'm sorry
man that's you dog you do believe that
>> it would give us Medicare for all. You're ruthless in
that sense. And so everything is up for negotiation. >> Hosan's
saying that Democrats would rather murder you than try to court
your >> No, no, but you understand what he's saying there
isn't that he's saying that they're unreliable.
>> Yeah. They don't really care about your
>> You have to address that though. >> Why are why
are you treating Can I ask you, do you think that Hassan is like
largely good faith? >> Uh, no. This is what it comes down
to. Uh, don't you know that Hsad is lying? Don't you know about
the podcast, the
deprogram podcast where he said he hides his power level? Don't
you know about
>> Don't you know about that? >> What are you doing?
>> I don't understand the defense. >> Why would you
defend someone who who you think is bad faith? Why would you
give them a m like this in this spot? Why would you not just
I already told you the M you're you compared his rhetoric to
politicians shifting their political opinions or support for
this or that
>> after the public gets on board with it. >> Yeah.
But no, that's Hassan's point. He might be wrong in the specific
instance of trans rights. And I think >> dude, Hutch
Hutch is actually is Hutch actually sitting here going, "No,
Hassan really believes that Gavin Newsome wants to shoot trans
people in the head." Does he Does Hutch really think that? There's
no possible way Hutch could really like Hutch is dumb, but he's
not that dumb, is he?
>> They have a good case there. But I'm just like, but
whether or not someone's bad faith, I'm going to like, you know,
I think Rob Nor is very bad faith, but I still like try to address
his argument as though we were good. >> But you said, but
wait. Okay. I I I feel very confused right now. Peace. >> I
don't understand how you tell me why you're confused. >> Operate
like what? >> I don't understand how I I don't understand
how you operate like this. If you tell me that you think Assan
is largely bad faith, why would you go to such extraordinary
lengths to reinterpret his insane rhetoric? Because it's the
obvious thing he's saying. It's just like, by the way, you could
just you could literally say, "No, I I think there is a good
argument against this." No, like Democrats broadly do try to
do things for trans people. They do spend political capital for
trans people. They did it before it was popular and they are
doing it now in in like at state levels. They're not running
on, you know, trans rights as a a national platform. But there
are arguments you can make against this. But but Hutch on the
national level does believe, yeah, I I could let trans people
go or I would vote for transphobes or I might even adopt messaging
that is counter signaling trans people or or some like youth
trans medicine or something because I think it's important. He
fully believes that in a way. Yeah, it's you have to fully believe
that and that's why you're arguing that MAGA is like fascist
because you are willing to throw some people under the bus. You
are willing to basically, you know,
put some people's stuff on hold to get rid of the mugger thing
to deal with that threat and then move forward. Right? That's
like the argument he's making broadly is it's so critical you
should be blue no matter who. I >> Hey, that is offputting,
man. It's offput. It's hard to watch. It's hard to listen to.
It's hard to engage with to be honest with you. >> Sanitized
sanitizing. >> I I'm trying to understand what he's saying
in the most reasonable way. And so when someone says like he
they would shoot you for a vote. I don't take that literally.
I take that as to be like they don't care about you and they
are basically willing to throw all their principles of the wind
for their personal political ambition. That's how I understand
that statement. Now, maybe I should interpret that that he wants
he thinks that Gavin Newsome is a serial killer. I just don't
think that's the most reasonable interpretation of what he's
saying. Maybe I should take a more unreasonable interpretation
of that statement. I'm just trying. >> But surely you know
that I'm when I hear him say that the Democrats would rather
murder trans people. Surely you understand that I'm not taking
him literally. I am. >> I I don't understand that cuz then
I don't cuz then the there's only one other way you could take
this, right? Well, okay. I guess you could take it. No, Hutch
takes it a different way. Sorry. The way Hutch takes it is Hassan
hates Democrats so much that he'll just say they don't care about
trans people at all. Like in a vacuum, they would never help
trans people. They just they they like trans people. We think
trans people lost this election. So trans people forever or something.
Could be something thought terminating like that. >> I
am looking for what he's actually trying to say. >> Saying
they don't really care about him and I'm just saying we should
address >> Do you think that's good faith? Do you think
that's a good good faith critique? >> Well, hang on. Good
faith critique means it's done honestly. I mean, it could it
could be good faith. I don't agree with >> Do you think
he's being do you think he's being honest when he says that?
>> Uh, I'm not sure. I think that they have insane standards
and so they really do think that like they could be honest about
their insane standards. You agree that they have insane genuinely
held insane standards, right? And that wouldn't be bad.
>> no, lefties. They'll be like, "Okay, but he said this
one thing about trans people in sports and that's the most important
thing and therefore I do believe they have no principles on the
basis of that statement by itself." Or they'll say something
like, "Well, AOC uh voted for the Iron Dome, therefore she's
a pro-Israel shill, therefore she's a Zionist." Like I I those
are just like some insane standards that some people have. And
so I in any given context, you know, you're asking me to be like,
"They're lying, right? They're lying, right? They're lying, right?"
Like I don't know. But but we're looping to my point which is
that the people the pe the people we're looping to my broader
my broadest point >> which is that the people that have
the most influence
>> in that space are using that influence >> in bad
faith ways >> deliberately to be dishonest to their audiences
and manipulate them into holding these
uh views that are frankly absurd.
When or let me put this a different way. When when Hassan does
that, when he uses that rhetoric, let's just focus on that specifically.
We could be broader with it, but like let's just focus on that
specifically. >> Gavin Newsome would shoot you to do to
uh for a vote, right? Or for trans >> Yes. Yeah. >> That's
not just an insane standard, though. That's disconnected from
reality entirely. I don't know what you're talking about, Pumpern
Nickel. Uh I don't know if you've been hearing what I've been
saying. I literally just said I I probably agree that like if
you just if you think if you think MAGA is truly fascist, you
probably do give up this group to just win elections. If you
that's probably if you could metaphorically shoot trans people
in the head and guarantee an electoral win, I think basically
everybody agrees to that. Metaphorically. Metaphorically, not
literally. Okay. Oh, the AOC Iron Dome vote. Yeah. Uh,
>> Okay. What do you think that lie? And and don't tell
me he doesn't that it's a lie. I mean, this is like there's no
there's no conceivable way that he doesn't know that blue states
and Democrats have been going about for there's no way he's not
aware of the different conditions for trans people and red savers
is a blue state. You would agree that, right? Like there's no
way he doesn't know
this. By the way, this is kind of like a total mislead, isn't
it?
Like if you have a if you have a totally blue state, like if
you have California,
is it not just like demonstrabably true that California people
by virtue of being super far-left leaning as a collective would
just want the trans bills passed? Aren't you just doing electoralism
in that district, in that state, in that wherever?
like like I I do believe there could be, you know, Democrats
in some purple states that are doing this, but just in general
blue states, I don't think that you're really sacrificing something
or sacrificing political capital to protect trans people. In
fact, I'd argue in California, I really don't like that people
are highlighting this a lot. The um oh, you can't like tell the
parents that the kid is trans.
I hate that bill so much. I I think that's like a totally wrong
way of looking at stuff. I think it's horrible policy. I think
it's like electorally like electoral poison. I hate that. I hate
that policy so much.
The one where like you can't tell the parents. Dude, come on,
man. I would say if you gave teachers protection in a situation
where the kid was alleging the parents were abusive, then maybe
you could notify a third party of some kind.
But my goodness, man, the idea that you just can't tell the parents
at all, that's crazy to me. >> That right. >> I think
he's ignorant in a lot of things. So, I think there is a way
that he doesn't know it.
>> You think that he doesn't know that it's way better
for a trans person to live in a blue state than a red state?
>> Oh, I think he probably knows that, but I thought you're
talking about the full paniply of different things the Democrats
have done. I think it's possible he's ignorant about that. I
think that he's aware that >> you fell for propaganda.
It's not It is that you just don't have to tell them.
So, there was it was the law before that you did have to tell
them. Is that is that what the law was before that you did have
to tell them? I don't you can say oh the law is that you just
don't have to tell them. Well, they made a law that was already
the law. I would imagine there's something else there,
>> It's better to be a trans person in Democrat state.
Yes. >> So then what he said has to be bad
>> Not necessarily. No. >> Okay. This feels like
a bit of cognitive dissonance to me. I don't know how you could
simultaneously think that Hassan is well aware
that states run by
are way better for trans people. And that means something. That
means like legislation policy, right? He knows that. I don't
know how you you could say that and then say it's not bad faith
for him to say that Democrats would shoot you if they thought
it got them more >> Those are different points. One is
about what Democrats are actually implementing. The other is
what they would implement if public opinion
They're different things. You >> Um, say it again. Dumb
it down for me.
>> Uh, okay.
Hassan's statement is about what Dems would do if polling shift
and your thing is what Dems actually do.
>> Different things, right? >> Okay. Hold on. Let
me let me expand on this point. going beyond the fact that I
I think it's obvious that Hassan
I don't I like
man I don't want to I really don't want to be an
I I don't I swear to God I don't I don't watch Hutch and I'm
like but like he actually
this is it's rough to watch when like he just doesn't understand
like at all. I don't
like because I think Pesco is trying to be as kind as he possibly
can and Hutch just like kind of doesn't
understand it. It's
And how do you explain to somebody who just doesn't understand?
How do you explain to them like kindly without sort of making
them look bad?
It's It's wild, man. >> Knows that blue states are passing
myriad bills to protect trans people. I think he knows very specifically
that that is what is going on. >> Okay. Um,
and I think he also knows that these efforts, >> so Pisco's
point here, which he has not said explicitly, but is implicit,
is that Hassan understands this, right? He's talking about basically
if polling shifted, there's no principled stance with these groups,
right? They've proven kind of that there's no real principled
stance with these groups. So, it's based on polling. Where it's
popular, they will do it. Where it's unpopular, they'll abandon
it. That's your position, Hutch, is that that's what they should
do, right? You that's like what you you think they should do.
And so we'd expect in the Adam Oler conversation this comes up
that Hassan would say, "No, obviously like your life would be
way better if you lived in a blue state versus a red state."
And there's like material differences there. But that doesn't
that doesn't preclude him from saying Democrats don't have a
principled stance with you. Yeah. It's uh it's all it all makes
sense. The >> have been unpopular with the public. So,
he's seen the polling that the polling the polling shows that
the voters themselves have moved right on a number of issues.
Therefore, he has to know that the Democrats have done this protr
stuff despite the fact that they've paid a political price for
it. >> Well, I'm not sure which of which is the opposite
of they would shoot you if it got them more votes. They're taking
steps that they know is unpopular.
>> I think they took those steps when they felt it was
popular, when there was a huge cultural wave behind them. when
they when they got way out over their skis on some of this stuff.
I don't think they've been taking those steps super aggressively
since they lost the polling, right? I think I think that's a
that's a way you could frame it to make it sound good, but I
don't think that's true. I don't think they've been aggressively
pursuing protrans policy since the polling's flipped on it.
Um, outside of the places where that policy would still be popular,
>> but they're doing it anyways to protect trans people.
that these these are as far away from each other as they could
possibly be. >> Yeah. So then I think uh so first of all
I'm glad that we're moving off of just the mere absolute fact
about whether or not it's better in blue versus red is enough
to know that Hassan is being bad faith. Um but again the fact
that it's nationally unpopular doesn't necessarily mean that
it's like locally unpopular in the way that they would internalize
it. And so I I think the um again just being totally good of
faith just because the Democrats are taking some measures and
I don't know if it's on stake is that those are the measures
that you think that are unpopular that should be taken but even
assuming that they are um in the context of a blue state where
overwhelming sentiment is with them. I think it's different than
looking at the overall national polls and saying you know um
that that they're doing it in that context. I think it would
be like where the winds are shifting in such a way that um they
should be receptive to it. And for someone like Newsome, you
know, he is charting a course to try to have a more um some even
say like sane approach to trans issues or whatever, a more moderate
approach to trans issues. Um that's a lane that he's self I think
carving for himself. Not to say that he's anti-trans or anything.
I would totally disagree with that. But um that I think is is
his critique. Not that um Democrats in places where they're safe
do things that are nationally unpopular, but in in situations
in which the polling is shifting in context in which it would
affect their ambitions, then they would shift. That make sense?
>> It does. But I have to say, Pisco, who is my boy and
I love deeply and has a degree from a law school, um, I don't
know how to reconcile
what you're saying right now, which to me amounts to making an
effort to interpret what Hassan said in good faith. Would you
agree that that's what you're trying to do? >> I'm trying
to interpret it in good
>> I don't know how to reconcile that with you saying 10
minutes ago that you think Hassan is largely bad faith. What's
the
>> Why would you make such an effort for someone who has
demonstrated that they will be bad faith at the drop of a hat
>> Because I think it's intellectually honest and consistent
of me to do so. And otherwise, this just turns into Hassan lies.
It's not bad. It's not bad. And there's like nothing of substance
for us to discuss other than he sucks. It's literally a circle.
Then what is there to discuss? >> Well, well, I think we're
talking about something like much bigger than just Hassan sucks.
I think I think I've made that point like clear that I think
it goes way bigger.
>> Oh no. Oh, this is where it starts to get very very
goofy for me. I watched I watched a little bit of this in the
middle. I just turned it on for a minute and I think this is
somewhere where I came in. This somewhere around where that dead
domain tweet comes up. But say >> I think this is around
where it comes >> You know, you on Monday like really grilled
me. You accused me of bad faith. And so I guess I'm I'm I'm a
little I'm a little confused of like why you would go out of
your way to try to >> uh so the difference there is when
you're participating live in a conversation with somebody, you
can see them contradict themselves in a way that shows you they're
being bad faith or stupid. Um and so you can call it out. When
you're just reacting to somebody, it's a little difficult to
say they're bad faith unless you have previous clips and stuff
and and you show the contradiction there. Like Hutch is very
often bad faith. When when Pisco catches you in a contradiction,
a overt logical like prop logic contradiction, and you refuse
to acknowledge it, that is literally bad faith. You are literally
being bad faith. Hutch is basically saying, "I don't understand.
You called me bad faith when I was being bad faith. So why would
you call us on bad faith right now?" It's like, "Well, because
I caught you in a contradiction that you refuse to acknowledge
and accept."
That's that's why you're getting called bad faith, obviously.
Okay. interpret what Hassan said in good faith when you say he's
largely bad faith. But when I tell you it's difficult for me
to justify voting for a Marxist Leninist, you jump to the conclusion
of well, you're being bad faith because you don't like him. Do
you do you think I'm more bad faith than Hassan?
>> I don't know how to make sense of this >> Yeah.
So like Hutch.
So again, I'll just explain it because it's going to be really
obvious to everybody. I'm not doing something special here. If
Hutch ever sees this, this is not special. I'm going to do the
thing everybody else can do. and you seem to be in a very tiny
subset of creators or even viewers who can't do this. Okay, you
in the moment were caught in a contradiction. You refused to
resolve that contradiction or admit what that contradiction like
what was entailed by your logical statements by the statements
you made. You refused to admit that. You refused to accept it.
You refused to like actually continue the conversation. That
is bad faith. So you were being bad faith objectively in that
conversation. And Pisco said you're being bad faith. So even
though he thinks you're good faith most of the time when he sees
objectively that you're doing it he calls you out as being bad
faith
when he's dealing with Assan he's trying to say well he just
gave his whole reasoning right the whole thing about we're just
having a circle drink or something and and Hutch does he can't
resolve how these things are possible but I'm good faith most
of the time and Hassan's bad faith most of the time but you call
me bad faith and now you say you're going to be good faith to
him I don't understand it's like >> in the context of our
conversation I don't know that I specifically accuse you of bad
faith other than dodging So dodging I think is uh bad faith.
I think he did dodge. Um but putting that aside like I think
that in interpreting Hassan statement everything I've said so
far has been reasonable. Like he's basically saying that Democrats
are fair weather friends. I don't agree with that as to every
Democrat. Some I do agree. Uh there are some Democrats who I
think are definitely fair weather friends. I think it's a reasonable
interpretation of what he said right now. And Hutch sorry Pisco
is being so kind by not just pointing out directly Hutch you
are defending being fairweather friends. You think we should
be fair weather friends. That's You think that, Hutch. You think
that, you advocate for that. That is the Green Lantern theory
of politics.
I think I still don't know exactly what that means. I've never
looked it up, but I think that's basically the idea that you
you should be whatever your constituents want you to be or something,
right?
Even if the even if it's against the principles of some of like
the majority of the party.
So like Hutch is that guy. That's the funny thing. I don't predict
you ever bad faith. I I don't know what interpretation of yours
was bad faith. I think there is some personal animist towards
Hassan and some might even be justified. I think that in some
sense you were justified to have personal animist against Hassan.
But um the question about Epstein I think brought out some what
I think are contradictions or at least entailments that you were
uncomfortable with and uncomfortable to reconcile. Um but I do
think I was trying to interpret you in good faith.
>> If Yeah. Yasaurus is exactly what's happening here.
It's just like a thing. Oh, they're bad faith. They're bad faith
forever. It's just one thing or the other. Yeah. If there's two
things that you because how long have we been doing the pod now,
man? Like a year and a half. If there's two things about me that
you know like really drive me is number one the principle of
taking the the harm reduction seriously. >> And number
and number two a principled positive view of liberalism. I mean
beyond positive I think that liberalism is like it's essential
that we maintain a liberal structure in this country%. And so
if I if I tell you that as a like principled liberal that really
values like the we could go into the minutia. >> It's all
going to be that Hassan is totally principally opposed to liberalism.
The idea of liberalism, the idea that you you do respect like
everybody's autonomy, the idea that personal freedoms, personal
liberty is important, right? Like classical liberalism.
I don't
I don't know like Hassan might be principally he might say I'm
principally against that. But in terms of like the democracy,
I don't think he's against the liberal democracy. I I mostly
think Hassan wouldn't be against the liberal democracy because
like in a non in a non-liberal democ democratic country, Hassan
is in a pretty small group of pretty extreme people,
he is going to be on the the bad side of that, right? He's going
to be on the wrong side of the the shutdown of liberal democracy.
So if for nothing no other reason, he's probably behind the idea
of liberal democracy because it allows him to have a voice and
to speak >> of like liberalism. >> This is the same
thing they do with Fentes, although I think it's far more called
for with Fentes because he's explicitly said we'll shut up our
opposition, right? But it's the same thing they do where it's
like, well, they, you know, we can never allow him to grow because
he's against liberal democracy. He he's trying to grow in power
and the second he does gain power, he literally will shut it
down, right? I don't believe that's actually the same with Hassan
to like the extent people pretend it is. I think Hassan's not
really that far off from a lot of other people in terms of like
he just wants to, you know, he thinks there's like far-right
white supremacist types who shouldn't have the right to speak
and should be re-educated, I think. Anyway, >> but basically,
we're talking about a system that was devised to to be a bull
work against a concentration of power against like the various
monarchies. You know, it was a principle of democracy a and and
all the values that uh that spring from that are things that
I think are really important in in terms of maintaining this
order. Things like the rule of law and free speech and the ability
to you know form political parties if you want to do that and
criticize the government and uh you know individual rights and
free markets and and these kinds of things.
>> Yo plant dad, thank you very much for the primer over
on Twitch. Thank you. Thank you. And and when I was telling you
that even if you put a preposterous hypothetical in front of
me, it's really difficult for me to ever entertain the idea of
giving a illiberal Marxist Leninist who believes in a uni party
the presidency you waited.
If that's your view, you should have granted it. If that was
your view, you should be like, "Yeah, of course I vote for Ebste
over Hassan."
>> You're doing it right now. Don't you see that? I feel
like you're trying to trap me in like you're trying to trap me
in the next thing, bro. You're just okay. You don't have to answer
it will matter. Whoever his opposition is, it doesn't matter.
If you tell me that my choices are a Marxist Leninist Tanky who
wants to end liberal democracy and anyone you can think of, do
you not think that it's like you not think that it is? No, but
you're you're >> if you truly believe this, then yeah,
it's absolutely Epstein over Hassan.
>> Like this is this is why by the way can justifiably
call Hutch bad faith because Hutch is quite literally refusing
to answer questions that are obviously entailed from his positions.
If you truly believe this about Hassan, like you might actually
really think that Hassan needs to be if Pisco is really if Pisco
is really strict on this. Okay.
>> Shouldn't like something be done about
Isn't he like kind of destroying your country right now? >> Doing
the prime Kai P.
>> Visco's not even at the Fed posting with Hutch yet.
Okay, I'm just kidding. >> Like you should know that about
me by now that I do consistently value these
Why would you conclin
the presidency? That's like pretty difficult for me. I >> I
I wish somebody at some point would just go, you know, Hassan
says he's not a Marxist Leninist, right?
And then Hutch has to go down that train of thought like, you
know, he says that's not true. You know, he doesn't think that.
He doesn't believe that. He's not He's not sitting here being
like, "Yeah, I'm a total Marxist Leninist." We doing another
night of Pisco glazing? Uh, I guess so. Although, the last time
I covered Pisco, I was actually saying I disagreed with him.
So, it's not it's not all the time, but it's some of the time.
Okay. This is important because it's going to lead us into the
actual mockler versus the song conversation. So, we'll see how
that
They assumed Aaron was a Marxist Lenist because she called herself
a communist. They don't care. They don't really care. Um
like all these people believe in achieving like socialism some
form of socialism democratically
that democracy is like essential to doing it. Winning hearts
and minds is essential to doing it. >> I would even entertain
you know reanimated Hitler or whoever you might think like it
might be a difficult choice. I mean maybe not Hitler that's a
bad choice. >> Hold on. Let me um >> let me let me
uh let me get some water. Give me like two seconds. >> Sure.
I'm allowed to respond
>> basically peo my boy that I love. I would like the same
charitability
that you seem eager that you seem eager to give to Hassan who
you say is largely bad faith. I would like at minimum the same
amount of charitability. Is that >> No, it's not unreasonable
and I I feel that I give it to you. I want to address some of
the things you said. So on the personal thing, I said that uh
before the hypothetical on uh on Epstein specifically, and it's
a true statement, Hutch, it is personal between you two. You
granted that in the course of this conversation. Me observing
that is I don't think bad faith at all. It's an accurate description.
on the specific hypothetical. I felt that that was a layup for
you. Uh a first of all, I didn't bring up Epstein in the first
context. That was you uh uh you know addressing IRI and you asked
IRI that question. Unless you're willing to grant that that was
unfair clip chimping of IRI, I don't know why asking you a similar
question is uh unfair.
>> But you were drilled >> because Pisco
because Pisco drills. Okay, it's this guy hard unlike Tetoone
who lies about it. Okay, Pisco drills down on people. Okay, Pisco
drills down because Pisco's like an obsessed
like obviously. So yeah, that's just a difference in temperament.
It's not like a difference in actual conduct or a difference
in like intent. It's just a difference in temperament. >> You
went into a mode. You were you were like just say it. Just say
you vote for Epstein. Say it. Say it, bro. Just [__]
it. I think you're motivated by this. >> Wait, no. But
but think about it, right? Like that should be a layup because
it sounds like what you're saying is I would never consider voting
for a Marxist Londonist and all the things about Stalin. then
why not grant it? And so the only opt, you know, the only option
is you wouldn't grant it because it would look bad. But any more
bad than saying you'd vote for Epstein over Trump? How would
that be worse? >> That's another thing that you know about
me is that I >> Another thing that you know about me, Pisco,
is that I will bite crazy insane bullets. I don't give a The
point of my hesitancy. Like that was the bigger point. Like the
fact that I would have to pause and be like, well, you know,
is Epstein uh committed to ending liberal democracy? That is
totally consistent with
my principles. >> I'll tell you why it's not. Because >> I'll
tell you why it's not. Because you >> come on. >> You
didn't consider that when you first said uh Epstein over Trump.
You didn't think, hey, what about Epstein's commitment to liberal
democracy? You didn't have to think about that. And so you'd
have to explain why you would have to think about it um with
Hassan, but you wouldn't have to think about it with Trump because
you already granted that before you even knew.
>> How? Wait, Pisco, how are you not connecting the dots?
What's the through line between Trump and Hassan? You think Assan
is worse than Trump, which is what >> No, no, no, no, no,
no. Come on. What's the through line between them? That would
that I would have an issue with. >> I'm presuming liberalism
and
>> You didn't need to You didn't need to know Epste's position
when you granted that Epste was preferable to Trump in election,
but you somehow do need to know it for Hassan. And so there needs
to be some >> We would need to I think we would need to
flesh out these hypotheticals a little bit more. Do you agree?
>> I think that that's fair, but you already granted it
with with >> There's a couple There's a couple different
ways that you could unpack like Epstein v. Can we can we please
like is there any other historical figure that you can think
of that would be better here? We need to move on from this. I'm
>> I'm not going to make you answer the question, Hutch,
but you can't accuse me of bad faith in the context of this specific
question.
You're making me forget. You're making me forget. Don't do it.
You know, I forget things. I get Don't do it. Okay, I've already
forgot what I was saying, chat. What was I just saying? This
is what you do. You get in my head with your lawyerly tricks.
I know what you're >> No, listen. I'm I'm defending myself,
which I think is my right. >> The two different hypotheticals.
The two different hypotheticals. That's I remembered. There it
is. Okay. >> The scope of accountability isn't even close.
Hassan supports Sharia law, a culture that marries 16-year-olds
as a part of their culture. And then Hassan throws shade at one
western guy who sleeps with teenagers. I don't even know. Wait,
are you I
Does Does Han support that stuff in the US at all? like like
I find it weird that Hassan would be a Democrat and also a Sharia
law supporter in the US domestically. I that feels odd but okay
maybe. So one hypothetical >> it's um it's it's uh Hassan
versus Vance and it's the current system the current guard rails
all of that like um you just copy paste right and and in in this
hypothetical you know Hassan knows that he can't get get rid
of liberal democracy so instead he just pushes for like social
democratic policies or >> right is that is that do you
think that's like like a fair way to frame the >> that
we can get into more specific >> I think if framed >> if
that is the case >> if that is the case I am obviously
going to vote for Hassan and spot over reanimated Jeffrey Epstein
just the same that I would AOC Elhan Omar Bernie Sanders obviously
if it's a hypothetical where you know re Vance or or or uh uh
that's a better more appropriate question by the way like Hassan
or Vance or Hassan or Trump or something like that but they have
built a political movement they have popular support they could
actually uh actually like meaningfully move towards their larger
goals then that uh that becomes a much much much more difficult
question because in both cases liberal democracy would be done.
And at that point, you have to to evaluate, okay, like do I want
to die, you know, 20 million Americans die from famine or >> Okay.
Yeah, that's that is your Yeah, that is your whole thing, man.
>> 20 million in the concentration camps. >> Yeah.
I mean, >> do you agree that that's like way to unpack
it? >> Well, I don't think I think it's a fair interpretation
of the question. I don't think like when people hear who you
vote for for president, they're like, who would you vote for
to have absolute like Dr. Manhattan powers over all our systems
and be able to like manipulate with ease? Um, I don't think that
that's a good like that's some [__] that Stephen
said when he was trying to, in my opinion, double back on on
some of the concessions he made uh on Twitter or whatever, but
I don't think there's any good faith reading of a question of
like who's for president like I'm voting for God Emperor who
has complete control of all the people and you know I control
the police down to every person like >> we would have to
but we would have to flesh out the hypothetical if you want to
flesh it out. I'm not saying you'd be inconsistent having two
different answers. What I was calling out though was what I'm
calling out though is you didn't need this kind of introspection
of the hypothetical for Trump. For Trump it was easy. Yeah, I'd
bite that bullet on Epste. Yeah, I would. But there's a different
treatment that you were doing with Epstein versus Hassan. And
that I think is telling because something needs to explain that.
And what explains it? That's my question. Didn't I say, Hang
on, wasn't I consistent? Because I swear to God that question
came up. Hassan versus um Trump. I think that came up like 3
weeks ago. Did I not say the same thing where I said I would
Minecraft >> Oh, dude. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Hold on a
second.
Uh, I just I I'm I'm totally pissed over by bringing this up,
but I just got made aware of a tweet that I have to pull up and
I think is really funny.
One second.
This one. Dude, people see so badly about this guy.
God, what a [__] epic combo. It's
basically I think Pisco listened to the Adam Mockler and Hassan
combo and was
"Oh, it's it's interesting that Adam's adopting like my way of
viewing the world and you guys are all kind of like blown out.
Like all of the whiners are blown out and and literally people
are just mad about it. People are just seething about it.
People are just totally seething. And I
Okay, I just feel like my way of looking at the world allows
me to predict things a lot more effectively. Okay, that's just
I think that's important. I think that's good, man. I think that's
good. I just I don't know. I don't know, man. It's It's fine.
I I got to mention it. >> I'm not saying that you're inconsistent
that you said I would Minecraft myself on that. I'm pointing
to something specific. That is to say, your willingness and eagerness
to be to show your consistency, which I think is great that you're
consistent on harm reduction was so powerful. A way to sort of
um test those bonafides was to say I would even vote for someone
I would find morally repugnant such as Jeffrey Epstein in the
name of you know societal welfare if it were up against JD Vance.
That was your statement. It wasn't accompanied by I would Minecraft
myself. It wasn't like I would vote third party. It was just
clear I would vote for Epste over JD Vance. >> I asked
you a No, no, no. I asked you I I tried to flesh out the hypothetical.
You were the one stuck on in debate mode because I asked you
what's his platform? Which is to say >> you didn't need
those answers for Trump and for fans. You didn't need those.
mean because I at that point wait no again stop doing this bro
I am consistent I literally said I would Minecraft myself between
Hassan >> that's not what I'm that's not the inconsistency
the inconsistency isn't that you would Minecraft inconsistency
is the amount of detail in the nature of the hypothetical that
you require for Vance versus for Hassan that's the inconsistency
why do you need more information about the nature of the hypothetical
when it came to >> why does it matter I was trying to flesh
out a hypothetical bro and I just want
>> it's it's funny because it's like sometimes you don't
No, this is uh how do I explain this? This is why like watching
Hutch for me as a political creator could never work because
Hutch is like very clearly
like I I'd say with me I don't spend a ton a ton of time watching
politics but I have like an ability to
understand like internalize understand and internalize people's
arguments in a way where like okay I can make sense of it and
I don't allow a conversation to proceed when I don't understand.
Okay.
I think Hutch makes it very clear to me over and over again that
he like doesn't really understand the stuff he talks about that
he's got very low like intellectual capability. I and I don't
say this is like to be a he's he's just not really capable of
assuming somebody else's position. He like he just he just doesn't
he he can't. The last time you did this he did understand. No,
he didn't. I was joking even less about him thinking it was literal.
I was like there's no possible way he could think it's literal.
He didn't understand the point Pisco was making. He didn't understand
the criticism Pisco had. He just didn't literally think that
Hassan thinks Gavin Newsome's going to shoot somebody in the
head. But that's like that's beyond anything. That's way beyond
anything. And also my whole point here even less is that Hutch
never understands this in the moment. He has to go and talk to
people and be told what to say. That's how that's my perception
of Hutch is he basically has to go and watch other people or
get the the stuff from Chatters, right? He has to get from chatters
to
like actually put together what his response should be sometimes.
Like I don't think he's actually internalizing this and and like
thinking about stuff. He's like not an uncarismatic person.
Like I I can understand why he's a streamer. I'm just
I I personally watch him and I'm like, dude, I think he basically
is putting this together from watching other people almost entirely
and I just don't I don't think I could watch politics from somebody
like that. Like I I could watch politics from Vosch all day cuz
I know Vos is basically I think Vos is like so egotistical that
he doesn't even have like group chats or friends that he talks
to about politics. He just like watches stuff and then he he
like watches a clip and then he has eight different he has like
a council of vosches in his own brain that he talks to and b
like battles back and forth with and he like predicts the scenarios
that will unfold from the thing that happened like like I could
watch that. Okay, that's like an interesting concept to me that
the the council of Voses comes to an opinion in in his own head
in in his own like free time. He'll like have political arguments
with himself. He'll play out scenarios. He'll do this whole thing.
Okay, I can watch that. I can't watch Hutch just basically only
reproducing other people's work like at any given point in time.
It's It's just not interesting. It's not It's not. And like I'll
give uh like I can understand watching honestly if you're if
you're a Hutch viewer, just watch Destiny. Actually, just watch
Destiny.
I'm sorry. Destiny is a far more capable thinker than Hutch is.
And and he represents all of your ideas better. You'll be far
less embarrassed. Okay, just watch Destiny. It's actually I'm
starting to think that like politically it probably like in in
in a very in just a raw your ideology winning sense, it actually
is better. Maybe this is all just a great SCOP from the DGG people.
Maybe none of it's maybe none of the people left. Maybe it's
the best scop was just platforming Hutch until people were like,
"No, just give us anybody else. We even take Destiny."
I don't know. I don't know, man.
Uh,
sorry. I saw a straightaway comment and then I I stopped I stopped
looking at chat. What did she say? Came in this combo proudly
saying he'd go with Epstein over Hassan, but he's clearly asked
mad about it. Well, I think he doubled down on it again in his
own stream, right? That he'd vote Epstein over Hassan. I think
I saw that clip. Our four hours uh or commentary Vos streams
are four hours of commentary about fashion and getting incredibly
frustrated with his chat. He's just angry that other people he's
basically like Vos comes to his stream and yes he talks about
fashion he talks about like the he's doing in his life and he
gets angry when people like want to talk about when people don't
want to do exactly what he wants to do or don't have his exact
opinion he gets angry about it
and then it's just him talking about his conversations with the
council of ashes he like watches a clip and he's like I've been
thinking about this and this is how this works it's very funny
man >> circle back to the point which is that isn't it
consistent with someone who thinks that the biggest problem that
we face in the country right now probably is I mean there's hyperpolarization
but like the threat to liberal democracy that is the thing that
I feel very vigilant about and so when I see apathy and intellectual
laziness and disengagement disillusionment nihilism alienation
bite the bullet for that can you explain why you didn't >> you
cannot get out of this mode and you're not listening to what
I'm saying >> you're doing it now you're in prime kai mode
is what you're doing right now
you don't want to talk about >> you need to you need to
answer my question okay If if you if you know this about me that
I think that the threat to liberal democracy is an existential
question that needs to be resolved. Is it not consistent for
me to want qualifiers in that spot? Is I don't know. Is Epstein
going to get rid of liberal democracy? Isan going to get rid
of liberal democracy? How is that
>> It's inconsistent with your prior >> I don't want
to be banned from Pisco's Discord. Oh no. I showed that thinking
Monk tweet and I don't mean to I don't mean to show it to get
him in trouble or to get Pisco in trouble. I was laughing. I
just took somebody I would never take screenshots of Pisco's
Discord and use them on stream for content. Somebody else did
it and I was criticizing them. Okay, don't ban me. Leave me alone.
>> So the JD Vance iteration of that >> Sorry, I
just saw Pisco ban the Thinking Monk guy or something or somebody
sent me a screenshot of that.
I might have Well, somebody sent me a screenshot. I just said
just leave me alone. I won't talk about it anymore. I'm shutting
up. Okay. >> Because when it came to that, you didn't need
to inquire as to Epstein's internal political views. You are
willing to grant that Epstein would be preferable without that
inquiry. That's the inconsistency. And presumably
please go >> I want you to just
I I really want you to just like engage in this question without
deflecting to a different
>> If somebody is principally concerned
of of the threat to liberal democracy. Is it not logical in the
context of asking me that question for a thought experiment that
I would want to flesh out whether or not reanimated epste would
want to would want to or be capable of ending liberal democracy?
Would that not make sense to ask that >> If by logical
you mean reasonable and in isolation, the answer is no. It would
not be um unreasonable to do that at >> You already think
Epstein is less of a threat to liberal democracy than JD Vance.
You already said you'd vote for JD Vance over Hassan,
right? Because he's less of a threat to liberal democracy than
Hassan. So no, it doesn't make any sense. Hutch, it doesn't make
sense. Hutch. Hutch. Hutch.
It doesn't make sense. Hutch. All I'm not calling in and of itself
I'm the incon doesn't relate to the inquiry in of itself. It's
obviously in comparison to some other question where the approach
wasn't taken. So that's what I'm call >> He said JD over
Aison. I'm almost Did he not say he'd vote JD Vance over Aan?
Is that not like the big thing that led to this whole hypothetical?
I'm pretty sure he did.
>> I'm I'm almost positive he did. That was like the one
nobody's even grilling on that one by the way. I'm almost positive
he said JD Vance over Assassan.
Right. Right. Right. Right. Right, right, right, right, right.
>> This this inconsistency that what you perceive to be
an inconsistency. >> But hold on. Oh, so you wouldn't vote.
So you wouldn't do everything you could to stop fascism.
That means you don't think there's any difference between Hassan
and JD Vance.
That means you're well, I guess you're willing to help JD Vance
take over the country. At that point, I roll the dice because
Hassan hasn't been implementing f like communism, right? I roll
the dice. I know with JD Vance where you're going. Uh, I yeah,
saying you treat yourself, saying it makes no difference is pretty
goofy. Actually, in the same vein as the Gavin Newsome JD Vance
hypothetical, it's pretty goofy. Is not relevant. It doesn't
matter. Maybe I thought about it slightly differently the second
time you asked me the question, and it occurred to me to flesh
out the hypothetical. >> You're right. You're right. You're
right. He did say he would shoot himself over over the question.
>> It didn't occur to me the first time, but it would still
be consistent with me being alarmed at the threat to liberal
democracy. But you didn't
you didn't even want to give me but you didn't even want to let
me flesh out the hypothetical. You're like you're you your whole
premise in that moment was the choice should be obvious. Like
obviously you would pick us on, right? That's what you're doing,
right? Either way it should be obvious, right? Either way it
should be obvious because if you view Hassan fundamentally in
in such a way that you it's essentially indifferent to JD Vance,
right? When you say Minecraft myself, you're kind of signaling
indifference. If it's the case that on in virtue of their threat
to >> you're obviously signaling indifference.
Hutch's whole thing is that you vote either way, whichever is
the harm reductive way, right? Literally, Hutch is violating
his own harm reduction principle by saying he'd shoot himself
in the head. That's not reducing harm. One of those options is
better. Tell me why you think one of those options is
That's his That's his principled stance, by the way. Um they
both, you know, are at least you're indifferent as to who you
vote for such you would Minecraft yourself. Then it should be
an easy yes, I'd vote for Epson easily. That should be the answer.
You didn't give that answer. That is a learning. >> Oh,
right. He So JD Vance equals Hassan.
Epstein over Vance
should be Epstein over Hassan. That's what the logic was. My
bad. My bad. >> On the other view, which is like no, please
go. Hang on. Hang on. Pisco. What is the difference in terms
of
a potential calculation between you forming the hypothetical
Hassan versus like Vance or Trump or Hassan Hassan versus Epste?
Like what? What? >> Oh, there's a way better idea. Straight
away. I got a way better idea. You could literally I'll just
join the Discord and you can cover this stuff with me, right?
That's trade deal proposed. You could just you could just hop
on and watch this stuff. >> You think the issue is there
for me? >> I'm joking, but also >> hopping in the
Why Why would I Why would I ask the question about Epste and
not Vance and Trump? >> Why would you ask the question
about Epste and not >> You don't have to if you're doing
other stuff. I'm I'm hopping in the Discord. >> Ask like
what are his politics? What are what's his policies? Presumably,
you're ignorant about Epste's political views. >> Yes.
Yes. I know Vance's politics. I know Trump's politics. I don't
know Jeffrey Epstein's politics. So, in that context, of course,
I would ask the question, right? >> If you're willing to
ask it in the context of the JD Vance comparison, then yeah,
of course, it makes sense.
>> Hear what I just said a moment ago. I know Vance's politics.
I know what he's about. I know Trump's politics. I know what
he's about. I don't know Epste's politics. So, why would I not
ask? But you said you would vote for Epstein over JD Vance if
there's a D next to his >> Because you already granted
the one, right? That was what the question was supposed to be.
>> Because I know their politics. I'm repeating myself.
Pisco, I know their politics. I don't have to question. I don't
need to know like, well, you know, is Vance trying to end democracy?
I don't need to ask the question. >> Then were you mistaken
when you answered so quickly that you would know that it would
be absent over Trump or Vance? Is that a mistake to answer so
quickly
>> without having done the inquiry? >> Because at
that point at all, please go. Is it not a coin flip at that point?
Like if I know that if I know that um like that that Trump will
try to do like a fascist takeover, then doesn't it make sense
to just like flip the coin on a candidate that you don't know
anything about? Now you can say you should have done that consistent
consistently in the hypothetical with Assan, but this is such
a superficial inconsistency. It doesn't matter. Maybe I was in
a different mood that day, but you didn't. You you jumped to
I think you're being bad faith and I think you're motivated by
personal grievance towards Hassan. you assumed bad faith and
yet in our conversation about Hassan right now you are bending
over backwards to interpret his statement about trans people
being murdered by Democrats in a good faith way after telling
you think he's largely bad faith now that feels like an inconsistency
I I don't think that I'm interpreting you with bad faith I mean
>> why did why did his son uh [__] h this is
so funny hold on hold on hold on apparently I should pull up
this clip hold on let me let me see here real
reading a tweet from right of Fuentes is JTO sends DG cult leader
omni liberal into con conspiratorial seething. I'm sorry I don't
I don't want to watch this but I I should probably just take
a quick look. Hold on. >> This is so funny. I think uh
I'm looking at the I'm looking at the comments and people are
saying I used to be an Adam fan but watching him sanewash on
the hunt is making me sick. >> Oh, I see. Oh, I see. I
could see how this looks like an op to somebody. Okay. I'm not
even going to say that this looks cuz I'm doing it sarcastically.
Right. Right. Fuentes,
I'm about to I'm about to chat dox the person who tweets this.
Okay, so you know that they're lying here.
I'm about to chat dox. I'm I'm two seconds away from chat doxing
if they keep doing this right of Fentes.
Okay, two seconds away. I'll tell you who that is. Two seconds.
Okay. Anyway,
J and definitely DM in the
>> He's reading a gistical tweet. Oh my god. They're the
signaling to all of these losers is so obvious. It's so hilariously
obvious.
Oh my god. I wouldn't expect any different from a guy who raped
kids in Germany or whatever.
>> Dude, I don't understand how people's brains work to
do his little
nuanced vision beyond like whatever the the clips that go viral.
>> This he was reading verbatim aistical tweet. This is
the signaling that they do. Yeah. To each other. back to the
marginal debate because it's mainly that >> I I fully admit
that tweet is a joke. That tweet is a joke about the tweets I'm
expecting to see >> unless you want to talk about that
one. >> 19 likes
and definitely they DM in the
We can do it at a different >> probably gets a decent number
of talking points from
me to task.
>> Not spite though, by the way. Definitely not spite driven.
>> All right, we'll do another one of these
I I wish I kind of I wish I wish.
Oh, actually, hold on. That is very interesting, isn't it, Nora
Blaze? That is very interesting.
He did see it before. He saw it. He's making fun of Hassan bringing
it up with 19 likes or something, but he saw it before that.
He was aware. Literally, when Hassan read it, he was aware that's
my Oh god, I'm the least popular person followed by the most
popular people. It's actuallyed up. Like, can I could I get These
guys have like what? I don't know. Hassan's got like 50,000 viewers.
Desi's got like 5 to 10,000 concurrents. And I'm sitting here
at like 300 just like tweeting stuff out. They're both reading
it. That's [__] up, man. That'sed up, dog. What the
Okay, that's the clip. That's the clip. Funny stuff. Very funny
stuff.
>> Can you point to an example of that? I don't know what's
bad faith about my What do you think? What do you think it means
to say I I don't think you're being honest. I think you're motivated
by uh grievance instead of um >> I don't know. >> That's
the definition of bad faith. >> Well Well, hang on a second.
I I do think that if accusing someone of merely being motivated
by personal as opposed to, you know, principles, I think, is
a way of accusing bad faith. Um but just to be clear, that is
different than interpreting someone in bad faith. And I think that
you granted that um when I said, you know, there's something
personal here, that was true. Um, and I don't think that merely
having some personal thing is by itself bad faith if you can
stand on principle and put aside the personal bias. Um, but I
again I think that the unwillingness to answer um and I I do
think it's a bit of a dodge. I think that's uh yeah, it speaks
for itself. I don't know that I use such biting rhetoric towards
you. And again, like look at how I I was happy to grant that
Hassan is bad faith way more than you. I'm happy to grant that
you know uh you are consistent on frameworks and principles in
general. Um I don't know what about my interpretation of your
comments was bad faith. Maybe you can identify one
>> that is my interpretation itself as opposed to piece
but I just did like if if I give you an answer and you say well
just just say just say you would vote for epste just number one
you were clip farming right there. Number two I want you to tell
me right now knowing like >> this is just lying. Wait wait
what what got said? I was looking at a DM. I was looking at a
DM from not Hassan [__] Okay. >> A bit of a
dodge. I think that's uh Yeah, it speaks for itself. I don't
know that I use such >> Yes. Yes. I don't even I can't
even like fake it. I honestly don't pay attention to Destiny
stuff beyond when he talks about me and have him like for weeks
now. It feels like or Pisco. Okay. One of the two of us because
I do I do feel like he attacks Pisco to keep him down because
he doesn't want Pisco to to leaprog him. But like I basically
only track those two things or I only see them. And so I actually
I can't even like give Hassan talking points. I would actually
suck at this right now. I'm like so behind on that stuff. I'm
much more if Assan needs talking points on like Techone or Knox
or any of that stuff. He can reach out to me for sure. The Destiny
stuff I'm like not researched enough. There are other people
in that. Okay. There are other people that would be better to
talk to >> fighting rhetoric towards you. And again like
look at how I I was happy to grant that Hassan is bad faith way
more than you. I'm happy to grant that you know uh you are consistent
on frameworks and principles in general. Um I don't know what
about my interpretation of your comments was bad faith. Maybe
you can identify one
that is my interpretation itself as opposed to inclus but I just
did like if I give you an answer and you say well just say it
just say you vote for Epstein. Just say just say it. Number one
you were clip farming right there. Number two, I want you to
tell me right now, >> it's like a it's like a solve for
X thing or something, right? Like there's there's just some logical
inferences you can make based on past statements you've made.
And Hutch
Hutch does believe he'd vote for Epstein over Hassan.
Absolutely. I just he just doesn't want to admit it. He just
wants to he he just keeps circling on all of this stuff. Messenger
I I tell everybody to watch an video. Also, Hassan in D in replies
to one of my tweets said he would watch the Nandros video. I
think he's going to do it at some point >> knowing like
with the context if if I as I am if I am principally concerned
with preserving liberal democracy and you agree that Hassan wants
to end liberal democracy, right? Like that's his ideal state.
He was want he would want to end liberal democracy. Do you agree
with >> Nothing that's entailed by Marxism. You can give
me then you then you can give me any hypothetical candidate that
in a in a contest with him and it would be a logical appropriate
question for me to ask what is their position on liberal democracy
right >> yeah I mean that would be totally fair
but you're you're ascribing to me bad faith and as though I'm
ignorant of your previous statement on JD which of course would
obviously color whether or not someone's bad faith >> then
it's such a
matter it informs my matter wait it informs my state of mind
right >> clearly it must inform my state of Wouldn't but
wouldn't me asking for qualifiers imply that I think that I intuitively
think that Hassan would be slightly better. If I don't need qualifiers
for Vance and Trump, I was like, "Oh, no. I would never vote
for them." But I need qualifiers for Hassan. Doesn't that mean
that I'm thinking more about possibly supporting Hassan? >> Um,
I'm not sure that it does. Um, I think if anything, right? Like
>> You're not sure? No, no, no, no, no. Come on. If I said
just unequivocally, you don't even need to give me qualifiers.
I would support, you know, reanimated whoever versus Vance and
Trump. And then you give me the same hypoan with Hassan and I'm
like well I don't know what's the that obviously means that I
would be more inclined if if slightly
then by the way then just to be clear your answer so Hutch this
is why we're operating off of information you've given us Hutch
that means if this is true then you pick Hassan over Vance and
Trump instantly you don't Minecraft yourself you don't kill yourself
you actually vote for the harm reduction candidate if that if
what he just said now is true Then one of the other givens is
not true. One of the givens is not true. It's really the the
the actual given that's not true is Hutch would just vote for
Hassan. Okay. He would just vote for Hassan. He wouldn't kill
himself if it was JD Vance with Hassan. He'd vote for Hassan
100%. Okay. More inclined to possibly vote for Hassan, >> Yeah.
But you didn't give that answer when Soyel asked you that. You
said you would Minecraft yourself. And so I have to take you
on good faith, right? I have to take you on good faith. >> Wait
a second. But you wouldn't give me an answer. Wait, >> you
didn't want to let me flush out the >> So, I just I just
gave you a response that that shows that I'm good faith, which
is I heard you be indifferent towards JD Vance and Hassan. And
that obviously informs whether I'm good faith or not. So, the
fact that I think that you're indifferent as between them as
opposed to slightly >> and and trusting you that when you
say >> this is wild. >> This is wild to me. >> What's
wild? >> The fact that I the the fact that I wanted to
flesh hypothetical out more obviously meant that I would be probably
more inclined to vote for Hassan.
>> Obviously, it means that. Are you more inclined to vote
for Hersan than JD >> Why do you think I didn't answer
it right away just asking? Right. Like why do you think I said
that? Right. Like I wanted to know. I'm like, "Well, you need
to like flush it out, right?" >> Well, I don't know why
you wouldn't answer right away. That's my point. I don't I still
answer. >> You didn't even But you didn't even want to
flush it out, bro. You didn't even want to let me do that even
though it's an appropriate question to ask. Your whole premise
was it should be obvious. And to someone who is focused on illiberalism
and is worried that liberal democracy might fail in my lifetime,
it is of course an appropriate question to ask. But you didn't
even want to grant me that. >> I don't understand why you
do that. in that setting and then you have to jump >> because
you don't need to. Again, I' I've already pointed it out.
>> That's not right. It's not right. It's not right cuz
he already said that there's no tangible difference between JD
Vance and Hassan,
right? So, it's not correct. He's saying those are equal. It
makes no difference him but he's willing to vote Epstein over
JD Vance.
Him needing a comment on Hassan or needing to know more about
Epste doesn't make any sense. One of those things is false.
He said he wanted to flush it out more. He doesn't have to flush
it out more. He has to reconcile the illogical statements. The
statements that don't go, right?
That's fine. But he should be allowed to do that. Why?
No, he has an error in one of his other statements that he has
to make clear.
You're just saying I should be able to filibuster on something
that's irrelevant because I don't I don't like that I'd have
to go back on something I said previously. No, correct the previous
thing and then talk about whatever you need to, but until you
until you correct the previous thing, you don't need to filibuster.
It's obviously true what you're picking. >> You jump through
these hoops to ascribe good faith to Hassan's rhetoric. >> No,
I'm not. >> You are not treating me the same amount of
credibility as you are. >> It's not true. That's not true.
I'm not ascribing good faith to >> I I think Hutch just
doesn't understand like you are you're you're you're
basically saying a logical contradiction for an
Internet debater, you have committed sacrilege, Hudge. You have
you have done a logical inconsistency.
Okay, you need to fix the logical inconsistency before we move
forward in the conversation. Now, I think I I think
maybe he could identify what I identified and just give that
to Hutch. Like, so obviously you go back to the the Vance equals
Hassan thing. That's what's obviously not true, right? You would
vote for Hassan over Vance.
Like obviously, right, Hutch,
because unless he gives that up and yeah, I guess you I don't
know about spiraling here, but unless he gives that up, it's
it's pretty obvious what's going on. Hassan's rhetoric. I'm just
trying to um you know, take the argument, you know, address the
argument in good faith. Not saying that Hassan is being good
faith about it. There's a difference between those two things.
>> But why would you do that for someone >> I do
that for Rob? I do that for Trump. >> You do. You assume
you assume good faith with Rob >> and for I need to watch
your last debate with Rob Nor. And for Trump, for his arguments,
yeah, I address them on the merits, even though I think he's
being bad faith. Same thing with Trump, right? Like I will say
afterwards, and don't forget, guys, Trump is bad faith. But I
will address Trump's arguments on the merits of their opinion.
I don't just say, "Oh, Trump doesn't believe this [__]
It's all bad faith." And uh, "All right, end stream." You think
I do that? >> What do you think I do that? Yes or no? >> There's
no way you're There's no way. You're saying that when you hear
when you when you hear um Donald Trump do his crazy cabinet meetings
or sit down
uh there's a substance tweet on this as well.
Wait, hold on.
Oh, did did substance snipe this one too? I'm going to retweet
this one. I'm sorry to the other person, but this one this one
doesn't call me right of Fentes disingenuously. By the way, disingenuously.
I'm going to retweet this one. Like this substance tweet, guys.
I
find it so crazy that Hassan reads off my tweet and just from
the words, Destiny immediately keys in that it's my tweet. That
is that just sends me that like he's streaming. He's watching
the conversation. I wasn't even watching the conversation at
this point. I fired this off before I started the stream,
right? It's just crazy that he picked it. He keyed in on it from
before I even tweeted. That's wild, man. It's wild.
It's goofy stuff, dude. >> On for an interview. You treat
all of his You make an effort to treat his answers in good faith.
>> Uh I address the arguments on their merits as though
they were made in good faith at times. Yes.
>> But why didn't you want to But but why did Hang on.
But why didn't you want to do that for me in our thing on money?
>> I absolutely am willing to do that and was willing to
do it. I 100% was. And >> if that was true, you would have
let me flesh out the hypothetical, don't you understand that?
If that was actually true and you were prepared to like allow
me to to to arrive to some kind of answer in good faith, why
would you not even want to grant the hypothetical? Why would
you want to just drill down? No, just answer answer. That's not
a trying to meet a good faith. Right. >> So So I listen
to you when you ask, well, I would need to know Epstein's um
political opinions. And I'm like, why? I say, why would you need
to know that? It didn't you didn't need it for JD Vance. That's
me addressing what you're saying. And maybe there's an explanation
there. Maybe you don't like that I harped on that, but that was
the basis. >> Well, I think I think it's obvious that the
reason would be that I think that Hassan is maybe more power
like Hassan I think the obvious implication there is that Hassan
is palatable in a way potentially palatable in a way that Vance
and Trump are not which indicates that I don't actually think
that Hassan is like >> how you know I'm good faith. How
you know I'm good faith is I still don't know your answer to
either of those questions. I don't know what your answer is to
JD Vance versus Hassan or Hassan V. Epstein or whatever permutation
that is. I don't know the >> you do know his answer. You
do know his answer and you have to press him to actually say
I pick Hassan over JD Vance for his own sake. For his own sake.
Hutch should just admit, "Yeah, I do pick Hassan over JD Vance
and Trump. I don't just shoot myself in the head. I hold my nose.
I go to the voting booth just like I'm telling everybody else
to do and I vote for the least harmful person."
Right? That's him executing on his principles in the world, obviously.
Right? He You have to do that. You literally have to do that,
man. Come on,
the answer. And so it's it strikes me as a little like how can
I be bad faith if I generally even now I don't know what your
answer is to those hypos. So if you want to be good faith here's
the thing though. Okay Killinger Dan did respond the other day
when he was watching me.
That's why I like Dan. Okay. Dan doesn't hide that he's watching.
Dan doesn't hide and he he like jokes. Like when Dan responded
that was funny. That was [__] funny.
Okay.
I I appreciate that Dan is willing to do content even when he
like doesn't like the person, he disagrees with the person. He's
like gonna he's gonna Hey, man. Come on, man. You happen to be
watching and he's like that. That's funny as dude.
Other people could never steal man. Okay, I want you to steal
man right now. Why Why do you think I would struggle making a
decision between Vance and Hassan? Um, Vance and Hassan presumably
because it's unclear which would be worse, Hassan or Vance for
society. >> Why? We just talked about it. Why? >> Because
you have some notion that like Vance, perhaps Hassan would be
uh pursuing policies or structural reform that you found corrosive
to social welfare and our >> We just said it. You just
said it. I mean I I opened up the stream by asking you you know
what do you when you say liberal what do you mean like what is
the through line between hassan and >> yeah it's obviously
grounded out into social consequences and benefits and so that's
all priced in and then after that I said and our foundational
values so I know yeah it it's I'm trying to price in everything
so both like consequences you think so for example you say USA
ID USA us cutting USA ID is consistent with the liberal framework
that's an example that you use and I'm trying to be as good faith
and as broad as possible to include both things that relate to
structural reform and you know the liberal system which is consistent
with cutting USA ID and also things that are not uh worth it
so I cut to the heart of the liberal structure. That's why I'm
being as comprehensive as possible in good faith by saying things
like social consequences which rounds out both. >> There's
like but there's like first order like fears and concerns and
then there's like second and third or whatever. I I've said it
10 times in this conversation that my first order like fear is
the end of liberal democracy and then below that we could get
into like policy
address.
No, but at the but at the very top >> my concern is that
liberal democracy might end. So is it or is it not reasonable
for someone like me with that fear? Is it could you not in good
>> you know what Hutch needs to do? He needs to answer
on this whole thing with the he'll say I don't entertain hypotheticals
with like public figure with um like influencers or celebrities
because I don't have a track record for how they'll vote and
so I don't know how my first order concern is is addressed or
how it will be addressed. Like I have no idea how Assan governs
so I'll never entertain hypotheticals with him because I do not
believe I'll never support like a candidate outright who has
no governing experience. I think that's the worst thing ever.
>> Right. And then you don't have to get into like mind
readading people. You could just step away from it. Now I don't
think he wants to do that because I think he in fact it is quite
important for him to say Hassan is bad. So I don't think he wants
to get out of it, right? But I I think that would be a good way
to just escape and and be able to address your first order concern
because I think a lot of people just look at it as like absurd
that you think Hassan wants to end democracy immediately,
right? I think that's probably where you need to go.
uh, I've been watching this drama and I'm Canadian, so maybe
I just don't see it. What's wrong with JD Vance? I get he is
manga and a little headstrong, but Hassan over him. Yes. Uh,
JD Vance is a
right? JD Vance is not even I say total. That's not right. JD
Vance is a
curated chameleon that will ex that will assume any possible
position or thought in order to obtain power so that he can be
a tool a tool wielded by the most powerful people in America,
the the richest people in America. That's that is why JD Vance
I say that's actually really helping him. Okay. It's it's that
JD Vance is like a a homunculus formed in a vat explicitly to
try to destroy your country.
And people don't see that, but they will see it eventually. Okay,
we'll keep saying it.
>> Good faith, grant me that that's a difficult, not obvious
uh question to >> As you're going to advance, >> yes,
if if my if >> you No. What? You don't think it's >> I
don't think it's reasonable to struggle on that answer. Now,
>> go, what? >> What are we What are we doing here?
>> What do you mean? Just like I don't think it's reasonable
to struggle on the Trump versus Newsome answer. >> Is Vance
illiberal? Yes. >> Is Assassan illiberal?
>> Oh, see this is this is my problem. Every single person
who who came at me for saying Hutch is actually smarter than
I'm willing to give him credit for. Kill your
internet connection. Okay. Uh get rid of your internet connection.
You shouldn't be on the internet. And everybody who who said
this about who said I was wrong about this, that's proof right
there. He just doesn't get it. He just doesn't he doesn't get
it. It's like not clicking. It's not clicking. Okay. Yeah, even
less was I'm talking to even less specifically in the chat who
was like, "No, actually you got it wrong. Hutch does understand."
I'm like, "No, he does understand like the the
uh contradiction he keeps going back to over and over again."
If if you could say Epste over Vance, Epste over Trump, Epste
if there's a D next to his name, then you should be able to say
Epstein over Hassan and Hassan over Vance.
Or sorry, not even necessarily Epstein over Hassan, but Hassan
over JD Vance. Yeah. Okay. Sure. Even less. Not in this case
though. Very correct in this case. >> Then what are we
doing here? Pisco. >> Why would you say that it's not reasonable?
Pisco, what is happening? >> Cuz I have a different view
on the level of threat to our liberal system as well as other
things that are massive
>> That's fine. We can I'm not committed. I'm not I'm not
committed that it's a reasonable position that one be kind of
like why why should I be committed to that reasonability? I don't
agree that it's reasonable. You want to say something I don't
agree with. I don't think it's reasonable.
It is. It's my You think it's >> No. No. No. Wait. I have
to think it's >> No. No. No. You If you're talking about
good faith and being charitable, you should be able to put yourself
in my shoes and and put yourself into my thinking without necessarily
knowing all the things that you know or having all the same exact
opinions that you have. But you should be able to imagine me
thinking, uh, that's it's kind of tough. You know, like Vance,
you know, >> your views, it's tough. Maybe maybe in your
view it's tough, but I have a different view. And so my view
on reasonability, I'm not just like incorporating your perspective
into my view on reasonability. I can be a reasonable person with
unreasonable opinions on some things, you know, like I'm I think
that I'm generally unreasonable, but I'm sure there are some
things on which I'm unreasonable. And so yeah, like I if I if
I were in your head, I would obviously think that your position
is reasonable because I would be you. >> Okay, that's what
I'm talking. That's good faith. That's charitability. That's
>> I don't think you're bad. I'm not saying you're bad
faith >> that but you did on Monday that but in this moment
you're saying that I can imagine someone struggling with that
>> No, I just think it's not reasonable. I can imagine
quite a lot. I can imagine people struggling with like simple
math problems. I can
Pisco is kind of helping I think Pisco is kind of helping Hutch
out here a little bit. Or sorry, he's not helping. He's not helping
Hutch out. He's doing the the is it is it possible that that
happened? Yeah. Is it is it possible I could I could understand
that? Yeah. Is it reasonable? No.
Just treat them as synonyms that it's reasonable. I think with
Hutch from now
>> imagine people struggling with you know um this kind
of question which is probably more reasonable to struggle with
than a math problem that's two plus >> I could
go Pisco he could get so many elbows in here that are so funny
it's like yeah I think somebody with Down syndrome could easily
think that Hutch yes I totally get it I yeah somebody with Down
syndrome could think exactly what you think >> too but
less than what I would call >> so why is it unreasonable
like do you think that Hassan would make any kind of efforts
to end liberal democracy boost our adversaries that he thinks
are morally better than us. Like why do you think it's why do
you think it's unreasonable for me? >> That's by the way
as somebody who doesn't think Hassan is evil. Okay, I will say
that is the most concerning part to me. If you're talking about
Hassan ending democracy in the US, I don't think that's concerning.
My concern is he takes his his boot off the neck of China. That
that would be the real concern. Okay?
Like that would be my concern totally. That's that's a actual
justifiable concern you could have that he doesn't think China
is like an adversary or that severe or significant an adversary
that he would, you know, abandon the island chain strategy. He
would start letting China do whatever they want. That's like
scary to me. That would be the actual scary thing. And Russia,
nope. Nope. I do not think China I do not think Hassan supports
Russia whatsoever in the same way. I do not think so. I I actually
totally disagree. People are like, "Oh, and Hassan loves Russia."
No, he doesn't. He loves the USSR what it was, but it's not the
same. He He does like current day China in a way that he does
not love Russia. Okay. I And I I would be terrified of what he
might do with the whole China situation. Okay. >> You'd
be concerned about Assan like damaging or ending liberal democracy.
>> Well, I didn't say that. I didn't say it's unreasonable
for you to be concerned about damaging institutions in democracy.
I said it's unreasonable to um to think that it's a tough question
as between him and advance. That's what I think is unreasonable.
Not whether or not Assan pose a threat. >> Wasn't the USSR
worse? Um, in some ways, yeah, the USSR was representative of
an ideology that he romanticizes and probably significantly like
downplays the atrocities of, but it's
like current day R. It it kind of gives away the dissonance there.
Yeah. But there's nothing I I don't think we're I'm not worried
about him supporting the modern day Russia because of his, you
know, love for for Russia or the USSR rather. >> Like obviously
grant that. And um notwithstanding our our it's funny people
send me this message be a tough question. Notwithstanding like
the the personal conflict or whatever I would vote for Destiny
over Hassan. I would uh you know pick Schumer over um Hassan.
I would by the way um
I would say like notwithstanding the
personal stuff which I might abstain over with regards to Destiny
like Destiny's politics obviously far closer to my politics.
I think giving a person with that sort of personality, I've I've
seen how that works out with with Trump. I just I think that
kind of personality shouldn't have power. So I I might argue
against it from that perspective. But it would also depend on
what the other side was, right? The other side's literally Trump.
I'd probably
But just in terms of the politics, I'd say Destiny's politics,
his his stated politics are more in line with my politics. >> Pick
um maybe not. I wouldn't pick over Hassan. Um but but like this
is all just a way of me saying that like yeah >> but I
might I might pick pick F over his own. I might in fact that's
my intuition. Yeah. But like the reason why should be obvious
to you and I again I feel like you're saying a lot of irreconcilable
things during this >> What's irreconcilable?
>> Because you're telling me that um it is reasonable for
someone who is uh afraid of liberal democracy ending
>> with everything in account. Um
I'd probably pick us on there. I I'd probably pick Hassan, but
that's on the belief that I don't think he tries to end liberal
democracy. I think Hassan does the intellectually uh humble thing
and just tries to pick policy advisers that while left-leaning
are intelligent,
right? I I think I think he tries to do that personally, but
>> Well, actually, no, you said
it's hard to comparison
all over the place, bro. It's not all over. I probably vote for
Hassan because I I think I get drone struck pretty quickly if
Destiny becomes president. >> Like is it unreasonable?
So if so >> that would be my primary. I in a hypothetical
world where I get a vote in the United States. Okay. I probably
vote Hassan because I just don't want to be put in a count myself.
>> It's not unreasonable that I would be concerned that
Hassan would really damage or end liberal democracy. If that's
not unreasonable for me to think, then it has to be reasonable
that for me this would be a difficult choice between him and
Vance. It has to be. >> No. because the magnitude of the
magnitude of concern could be hugely different and it is make
sense. >> I think the reasonable position for you in this
spot is to say, "Yeah, I can understand why that would be a difficult
choice." Now, maybe we can have a debate and and that could be
like a fun exercise of like here's why I think the magnitude
would be worse over here. Here's why I think the magnitude would
be not as bad over here. That's fine. Like I I mean I would be
down to have that conversation because I feel like there's enough
of Hassan's rhetoric for me to say that I think that this guy
was like Daenerys Targaryen basically. Okay. But like you can
have a different view of that or whatever. That's fine. Like
>> what is Hutch even arguing now? Hutch is basically saying,
even though I'm logically contradicting myself, you should just
let me explain.
It's like, no explanations, fix the logical inconsistency.
Just fix the logical inconsistency first is what Pisco is trying
to say. And Hutch
can't perceive it or do so. So, it's I don't know what it's converia
of that debate without you. >> We're almost at the end
of where we go with this. I don't I don't know if it gets any
better from here. Can anybody tell me does it get any better
from here? I feel like it's going to be circling on the same
stuff. Maybe we'll watch for another five minutes and then I'm
basically ready to go to Hassan Mockler and then we'll see from
Hassan Mockler where we go if we're going to do >> It's
unfathomable that this would be a difficult choice >> for
I'm basically ready to go to Hassan Mockler and then we've got
a couple other segments. We'll do the Asminold stuff after that.
Okay. Very excited for the Asmin Gold Orbiter segment. >> Watch
this chorus part. What is this? Oh, is this from Hutch and Pisco?
>> Oh, okay. All right. This is uh Wait, wait. They talked
for like two hours. Holy.
Yeah, I I couldn't do that whole thing, man. That would be a
lot. That would be a lot, dog. >> Be um You're too important
to be um What did you say? You're too important to be having
a conversation with these course people. No, I need to do a little
bit of cleanup here. I think you guys don't
>> There needs to be a cleanup here. >> Okay. There
needs to be push back here because these guys do speak directly
[__] consultant class. That's why Trey East of the
Search. >> He's [__] questioning my judgment.
>> It's such a good clip.
>> Oh, this is so cringe.
Oh, Hutch can't not be cringe, man. Hutch is Isn't this bad?
Oh, he thinks like people basically aren't like have the wrong
opinion of him, the wrong impression of him. So, he wants to
talk to them directly. Is that
Hey, I think these people have the wrong impression of me. I
I'll uh probably talk to them directly. Is everyone bad in a
class? No, he he doesn't. This isn't about disliking the consultant
class. That's not what it's about. This is like actual like some
kind of actual understanding of politics here. He's like, "Oh,
the people who are like movers and shakers in the Democrat scene,
um, some of them are listening to this and so I need to do some
cleanup. I need to talk to some of these people and like make
sure they understand that this is not quite what I think." Which
is probably why he went and talked to Adam Mach to tell you the
truth. I would imagine, right? He wants to clean up what he thinks
a little bit.
seems to be the case. >> Underappreciated
judgment here every now and then. Can we Can we of confidence?
>> Okay. One sec. One sec. >> You're still You're
still muted, by the
>> My bad. My bad. Yep. Saw the clip. Just Just give me
one second to restore
>> That's so good. That's such a good clip.
>> Okay. So, he said, "Uh, let's do a cleanup here." And
then he immediately proceeded to go on Twitter and like talk
[__] right? So, not immediately. No, this was like
a few days later. >> There was some creator, the context
of the post from last night was there was some creator that um
he posted a, you know, like a pro crockett uh video down
>> And then Hassan quote retweeted this person and said,
"Corusfunded creators need to stop doing like this straight up
Israeli asset." >> Okay. First of all,
where is he getting that this person is a chorus creator? Like,
where where did he get that? The >> I have no idea. >> It's
Alex Jones is my point. I mean, >> he tied it to Israel.
>> Unless there's a basis unless there's a basis to know
that. Yeah, I would agree.
>> Yeah, he tied it to Israel and then uh you know, Brian
called him out and then
uh Hassan said what he said. But like this this is my point where
>> did Brian post the list of creators and we have a lot
of pro Palestinian leftist creators in chorus.
Okay. Post the list.
Uh actually there's a woman who said she's a part of the funding
program and she's pro Israel or sorry pro Palestine. Okay. But
disclose the list. You understand if that's like your only one.
You're just lying to me directly to my face. Like you are you're
trying to say that we support these voices so you should be happy
with us. But if you're if you're literally flooding the zone
with with other talking points that totally undermine mine, you're
not helping me. You're [__] me and then telling me
you're helping me. Okay? Do you understand?
Like that is the obvious problem. If you have one person in there
and I don't know what the actual truth is, by the way, I personally
don't know.
So I'm willing to say, but I I'm suspicious that it is not mostly
pro Palestinian people.
But the ratio would be important to know
and for them to not say what the ratio is or for them to not
publish a list of creators. I think personally
it it's obvious. I don't know. Maybe it's not obvious. Is Ariana
Jasmine the only one? I don't know if Ariana Jasmine's in chorus.
Somebody asked is Ariana Jasmine? I don't know. I don't know.
I don't know why I'm saying Jasmine instead of Jasmine either,
but it's fine. It's fine.
Um, I heard Mika Ran, who's going viral lately, is also a chorus
pro Palestine creator. I don't know who any of the course creators
are. I really don't know. Yeah, exactly, Kilo. Yeah,
Um, there's there are Yeah, there are other things to criticize
about course or that you could criticize, but it's like difficult
to make any of the criticisms when everything's um opaque. And
unfortunately, I'm starting to get very suspicious of stuff like
that because that is exactly how I think I and a lot of other
people got fooled on the Israel Palestine situation to begin
with. It's like, well, actually, somebody's keeping everything
opaque who could make the information public and allow you to
make a decision. And it turns out there's probably just a reason
to suspect that if they're keeping everything opaque, there's
a reason for
Like I I'm sorry if like if your actual outcome uh and it's hard
to say even for with the Israel Palestine situation is like the
people who could give you the the decision-m criteria for strikes
and all of this that there's none of that really published, right?
and the outcome has been disastrous. Now, I won't say the outcome
of course has been disastrous for like lefties even yet because
we don't really know, but it's it's just I I dislike um keeping
things opaque personally.
But I think I argued this during the chorus thing. I think that's
fairly critical to them making the program work. If you put a
chorus logo on all of those people who are chorus influencers,
those people start getting discounted for being chorus influencers.
And I think they also know that >> where it's like hubris
and stupidity.
So like he does think that he can have it both ways where he
can just deploy this, you know, chorus attack anytime
I guess anytime a creator posts something that he doesn't like.
>> Well, I guess is what's happening here. And then at
the same time, he's like, "But but chat, you got to trust me.
I got to repair I got to repair with Brian. He's got too many
DC consultant friends." Well, I would jump in my mentions this
morning. >> Again, I just don't know if this is the best
example of of like an inconsistency on that thing. Like I totally
agree that it's um Alex Jones asked to uh assert that they're
um I don't know corresponded if there's no proof of that or no
basis to believe that that um that it's done to avoid Israel
criticism. I >> Oh, that dude is literally on the chorus
newsroom interviewing people. It's pretty open about Zachary's
involvement. Zach is open about it, which means Hutch is either
lying or refuses to look it up. Oh, so the guy's just like open.
Oh, so Hassan's like Alex Jones. Um, do you notice how Pisco
just answers conditionally? Yeah, I guess like if there's just
no way to know this, then then yeah, Hassan would be look he
would look pretty crazy. He just answers in the conditional.
He could think in hypotheticals. He could think on either side
of like some condition, right?
Very interesting.
Hutch just doesn't do that. And Hutch could easily look this
up and not look silly here.
I do wonder why he would bring this up as like a major point
to attack on without looking anything up as Hold on. Somebody
sent me Taylor Loren's report on him being in chorus. Hold on.
Is that true? Is that true, Chad? Is that true? Is that real?
This guy was in the chorus 1630 dark funding program. By the
way, content like this is certainly profitable.
Wait, hold on. Where do you So you say she reported on it.
She says this. Where's the Where's the proof of this? Other than
I guess if he's involved with the chorus newsroom. Sorry. This
is not That is him in the chorus newsroom. Oh, this is literally
like a newsroom. That is the chorus
Oh, I see. I see. I see. I see. Oh, no. Matt, you linked something.
Sorry, sorry, sorry. I thought you were talking about what's
on my screen. This is him in the chorus newsroom. Ah, okay.
>> Offense time. We might be the party in
Dude, Hassan is like basically Alex Jones by assorting asserting
that this guy is a part of chorus. It's like Alex Jones basically
more or less Alex Jones. Okay, Hassan and Alex Jones basically
the same guy.
I certainly don't look saying that without even doing the baseline
due diligence on this topic.
Um I don't know for sure that you have to be in the funding program.
He's definitely affiliated with Chorus. I don't know if you have
to be in the funding program to be in the newsroom or be on their
their feeds, but I do know this newsroom is specifically meant
to be like with their incubated creators as
Like there's affiliation there. So
I'm saying to me saying he's like
It's like not it's directionally correct no matter what. They
might try to be like ticky tacky. Oh, he's like he actually graduated
the incubator program weeks ago or something. I don't know. I
don't know, man. I'd say that's more or less enough for me to
say that Hassan's not Alex Jones. Okay, >> agree with that.
But like it doesn't seem to be inconsistent with trying to repair
relationships with Brian Tyler Cohen. If anything, it would show
like integrity if he actually believed it,
>> But he doesn't though is my point. Do you think he actually
believes it? >> I'm not sure that if you mean like is he
actually lying about what he thinks Chorus is with respect to
>> Do you think that Do you think that he thinks that he
can just call people, you know, Chorus created uh Chorus? uh
you know, Israeli assets and and he knows that just a big chunk
of his audience will discredit those people like in their minds
that person will have been
>> He's on the Corucket Chorus website.
How do you even handle this if you're Pisco? It's so rough, man.
It's actually so rough if you're Pisco. It's like, okay, so you
understand that you basically you basically said he's like Alex
Jones. He basically said he's like he's like the guy who said
that those dead kids' parents were crying cuz they're crisis
actors. The kids were crisis actors. The kids who survived at
Parkland like that's that's you understand that that's who you
are right now, right? Oh, wait. Was it Was it Parkland? No, it
was before Parkland, right? What was the shooting? Was it Parkland
for Alex Jones? Which one was it? It was one of the big ones.
One of the big famous Sandy Hook. Sandy Hook. Right, right, right,
right, right. I didn't think it was Parkland because I I know
the people who came out of the Parkland shooting as like influencers
and I'm like no, Alex Jones wasn't related to them. It was Sandy
Hook, right? Because Sandy Hook is like the elementary school,
right? It was very sad. Very very little kids. Very sad. Anyway,
I'm just sitting here. It's like you basically totally accuse
this guy being like the worst kind of liar and then it's like
he's the guy we're talking about is on the chorus site. >> I
just don't I don't know, man. Therefore, dot dot dot you don't
have to like listen to their criticism or pay attention to anything
they have to say. They're just coorse Israeli assets. Like that's
what he's doing. It's
>> it's almost it's almost like saying somebody's a Marxist
Leninist when they disagree with that, right?
It's a Marxist Leninist. And because that ideology is not compatible
with liberal democracy, you get to discount everything they say.
Wow. Sounds like Hassan might be picking up Hutch's playbook
a little bit here. >> All a big effort to discredit people.
That's is like his MMO
>> knowing that they're not corresunded.
>> No, no, but specifically like tying it to like is Israeli
propaganda which is what that's what that's what he does. Like
the chorus thing is just for him a vector uh to you know tie
it to like the broader kind of Israel stuff. >> Got it.
But like can we just take this one at a time? So, this guy Zachary
Kirk, is there a basis to believe that he's a chorus funded creator?
Well, there's somebody in my chat that is saying that um Taylor
said he was in chorus, but that's again that's not the point
though. That's not the point. Like he's using Chorus again. >> It
is the point. It is the point. That's literally that's where
this started. He's just lying that he's just pivoting and lying.
That was your point originally. That was originally your point.
There's no reason for his son to believe that he's even in chorus.
I uh do I have a transcript on this yet? >> I don't know
if I do. Hold on. Let me uh let me reload.
That was the point he was originally making. Now, there is a
secondary point about the Israel thing, and you could get mad
about that. Okay, >> you could get mad about that. I still
don't have a transcript.
Okay, hold on. Where were we here? We're right here. So, it's
somewhere between these. We'll go back just real quick >> as
he's framing them.
>> Oh, wait. Okay. All right, this is the one here.
>> Understand? Okay, hold on. Hold on. >> Uh video
down here.
>> And then Hassan quote retweeted this person and said
corresponded creators need to stop doing [__] like
this straight up Israeli asset.
>> First of all, where is he getting that this person is
a chorus creator? Like where where did he get that the [__]
>> First of all, my primary contention, where is he even
getting that this person is a chorus creator?
Fast forward to
like 30 seconds later. Hold on. I'm gonna have to go back a little
bit here. One at a time. So, this guy Zachary Kirk, is there
a basis to believe that he's a chorus funded creator?
>> Well, there's somebody in my chat that is saying that
um Taylor said he was in chorus, but that's again that's not
the point though. That's not the point. Like >> That was
the point. That was literally the point.
That was literally
the point.
Well, so there's a second point about tying it to Israel, which
Hutch doesn't like either, and I've already explained like where
that comes from. And I think
I I think they could just make their list transparent and dispel
this entirely, right? Obviously.
So, this was a part of it, though. This was a big part of it
is he doesn't have any way to do this. It's It's like Alex Jones.
He has no basis for it. >> He's using Corors again as he's
>> Hold on. Can we go back to this one? Let's keep going
here. >> It's Alex Jones is my point. I mean, >> that's
that's where the Alex Jones point comes in is you have no basis
to believe this. You're like Alex Jones. So, he basically just
comes on here. He says Hassan's like Alex Jones cuz he doesn't
even know if this person's in chorus. And then later he gets
called on it by somebody in his chat and by Pisco cuz Pisco probably
is a similar person in his chat, maybe the same person even.
And Hutch backpedals and just lies.
Now, I understand why that might be difficult for Pisco to pick
up in the moment. I understand why that's like kind of annoying.
I also understand that there are people who will take any any
anger he has with Hutch out on him like directly. So, I do get
it's all a little difficult. Okay.
It's rough. But I just feel like that's this if you want to talk
about Yeah. bad faith, man. It's rough to follow this conversation
and see where it goes and not feel like Hutch is being kind of
a piece of [__]
I'm sorry. He's framing them as a organization that is doing
Israeli
>> I would say that the framing there is implying that
like there's a broader pattern of chorus apologia
for Israel. Um although I want to say that that's like a level
removed from what I would like I I thought that there was no
basis to conclude this guy was in chorus. Um, but I'm I'm happy
to say that like that part of the framing as you know, chorus
is in the tank for Israel without additional evidence. I don't
agree with that framing. But I would put that at a different
level removed than like just claiming people are so Pisco does,
for anybody paying attention, Pisco does point out that like
your original contention was this. So, but also like the Israel
part, I guess I can give that up that I don't know that there's
evidence that it's pro-Israel overtly.
Um, I do think that assumption is made based on the founders
and based on some of the founders like principles or what what
some of the founders have said, right? Or the I guess even silence
on the issue, right? I I can understand like where it comes from
just with the people listed,
right? But I don't I don't think it's like supported that they
only fund or or that they largely fund pro-Israel creators. It's
not supported. I would agree with that. >> Cororus is funded
because of their Israel takes, you know. Um
>> um I thought the Israel comment was aimed at the specific
creator. Uh
hold on, hold on. Do you think so? Do you think so? Do you think
so? Cororus funded creators need to stop talking like this straight
up Israeli asset.
I think there's an implication there as well. Um, if he wants
to clean up that implication and say that he doesn't think Chorus
is doing Israeli stuff, like unfortunately, if he wants to distinguish
himself
from like Taylor Loren and a lot of the people around him, he
needs to actually make sure he distinguishes himself. Okay.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. This is one of those things.
It's like the Kamala thing. Okay. He does actually need to distinguish
himself because a ton of his friends do believe chorus is like
an Israeli funded thing that is explicitly looking to support
Israel as much as possible. Okay. So if he was not saying that,
if he was not giving that implication here, then he needs to
actually like word the statement differently cuz I will take
the implication away and maybe that's unfair but based on his
friends and stuff.
I would assume that is because I remember when I covered the
chorus stuff, I watched Taylor Loren go on Glenn Greenwald's
show and say explicitly, I think this is all about funding Israel
and and they had a little circle about it. Okay. And I was like,
I don't see any evidence of that yet. I I am suspicious because
of the uh I'm suspicious because of the lack of transparency
here. Okay.
Did you read Hassan's screenshot in the quote tweet? QRT. What
is this? Uh
Elon Corey Bush. I I'll bet this is about ideology. So, you didn't
support Ilan Omar or Cory Bush? I didn't support either one.
And for the record, I strongly support these two people. Now,
go cry about it. I don't know if this doesn't prove anything.
This doesn't prove that he's pro-Israel,
although he might be.
Anyway,
anyway, anyway, anyway, we can go back to this tied to Israel.
>> Unless there's a basis unless there's a basis to know
that. Yeah, I would agree. Yeah, he tied it to Israel and then
you know Brian called him out and then uh Hassan said what he
said but like this this is my point where it's like hubris and
stupidity. >> Oh, I see. So basically those people are
like um like
like uh uh what's his name? Torres. They're they're like to Torres,
right? Dicky Torres. Dicky to That's who they're like. Okay.
Okay. I got >> So like he does think that he can have it
both ways >> where he can just deploy this, >> you
know, chorus attack anytime I guess anytime a creator posts something
that he doesn't like. Well, I guess is what's happening here.
And then at the same time, he's like, "But but chat, you got
to trust me. I got to repair." >> Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry.
This is uh this is where we were in the combo.
>> Does that make sense? >> Done that down for me.
Dumb that down for me. >> So, if there's a >> No,
I I can I can think about that and and understand it. Okay, I
can understand it. >> Basis legitimately to believe that
a person is chorusfunded.
and it seems like in this case there might have been a basis
to believe that he's chorefunded. than saying things like chorus
funded people need to stop doing X Y or Z or chorus fundded people
need to do you know with reference to a specific purpose it starts
to feel less of Alex Jones like except to the extent in which
he's playing in this framing of chorus um kind of implicitly
this framing that chorus is a Zionist project which I will grant
you that that has been the narrative that a lot of lefties including
Assassan have promoted but I just it doesn't feel as Alex Jonesy
that
>> um well I I think even above at more meta level above
like the Israel stuff. The I think like the >> I just think
like it's really rough for me when Hutch just like I start to
lose the
charity I give of Hutch being a total who doesn't know what he's
doing when he can so effortlessly like a duck with water getting
poured on him. Like sherk off the lie he just did. He just totally
got caught like making something up. He just totally got caught
speaking at a level of confidence way above what he could prove,
way above what's on the record. And then he and then he just
keeps going as if he didn't do anything like so effortlessly
to me. I'm like, "Oh, I stopped looking at this guy like a I'm
like, "Oh, this is actually uh a little worse than that." It
looks like >> broader claim about Chorus is that they are
um a slush fund to pay creators to push the Democratic establishment
like party line. And so they've
>> they are that they are that. And and I by the way, I
don't even necessarily have a problem with that. I don't even
necessarily have a problem with that, by the way. But they are
that and and the idea that they're not that is you lying to me.
Don't lie to me. Don't lie to me. Okay. You they they use Taylor.
I say they I mean like the populist left or whatever. We'll be
we'll be just like very broad. Um they use course as a way to
sort of get people to dismiss anyone whose opinions they don't
like. So like I disagree with this creator that Jasmine Crockett
is the better candidate. Okay, that's but that's fine. That's
not a that's not a big deal. But like Taylor takes it further,
right? Ryan Tyler Cohen told the New York Times that that was
the purpose of Chorus. He also said before he started Chorus,
around the time he started Chorus, he literally went on a certain
streamer stream and talked about that's why he wants to start
a company that's doing this kind of thing. And I'm looking to
recruit streamers who will help me in a company who's going to
be the going to make it so Democrats are day one with messaging
like Republicans. We're going to wake up like Republicans and
it's going to be like we're in a morning meeting, guys. You know
how Republicans sometimes it's like they're they're in lock step
like they had a morning meeting with the talking points. We're
gonna do that for Dems and then oh look we here we present chorus
guys but because of our because of our financing structure because
of the way our corporate structure is laid out we have to say
we're apolitical.
Okay. And then I'm like oh that's like a damn thing. And Hutch
is like there's no evidence of that. It's like you're saying
it's like a a slush fund to push damn messaging.
Yes. Explicitly so. Yes. You can't say it because otherwise you
would have to get money in a way more transparent and way less
uh lucrative way. Which again, if you want to say, "I hate fascism.
I hate the fascist MAGA party and I hate that they can take dark
money like this and all of their creators could take dark money.
So, we need to we need something to fight back." Okay, cool.
If that's if you're willing to say, you know, nuclear options
been invoked, we have to go we have to go with this. That's fine.
Just don't call me a liar when I say it's like a obvious demfund
whatever to push dem talking points because that's what it is,
right? So like you know I pull I'm just pulling up a tweet of
hers on the screen right here. >> You know um she quote
retweeted the same thing and said this guy was in the core 1630
dark dark money funding program by the way content like this
is certainly >> So like I think the obvious
um inference there is that this creator is being paid to you
know like Eiffel the populist left which in this case would be
Terico, right? like they they've they've you know the the the
populist left they've caught on to kind of Rico in the last week.
I don't know if you've noticed but >> yeah big been talking
about him positively and Assan's been talking about him positively.
>> Yeah. I sort of I'm getting prepared to make some endorsements
myself. I'm guessing it's like Israel positioning that Terrio
is more um openly against Israel funding than Rocket is. >> I
don't I don't know if he's even spoken about Israel yet. I think
it's more that he's a populist. >> Did Hutch take chorus
money? Um I don't know. I don't I don't think it would be a significant
enough portion of Hutch's overall income that he would care so
much about the course funding that he would um like significantly
change his positions before or after. Like Hutch already believed
all these things. Hutch is already on this page. Like Hutch wouldn't
be somebody that I think Chorus would pay for because Hutch already
would do all of the things Chorus would want him to do. Why pay
somebody who you don't have to like you don't want you don't
need to give any talking points to Hutch? Hutch is there like
he's already the number one paratrooper. Okay. He's like the
number one shock trooper for the damn party already. He's you
there's no reason to pay this guy. >> He's like he's like
okay. Shh. Don't give them ideas. Don't give them ideas. Don't
give them ideas.
Do not stop. Very important Hutch stays in power. Okay.
Um
funny thing is that even though Telerico swore Apac money, he
took money from Miriam Adel said. Yeah, we just saw that. Yeah,
we just saw that
he did take money from Miriam Medson. I don't know why, but like
unless he was wooing that money somehow, right? Unless he was
changing a position somehow, I don't really care.
I I see that Miriam Mlesen donation as strategic by Miriam Mlesen
unless proven otherwise. Unless I could see some reason that
he took that donation like that's different. It was for gambling.
Was it Miriam Mlesen soothing her conscience or was it her trying
to get gambling promoted? He said Texans want to gamble and so
he took it. Oh, that's rough. That's him. That's him accepting
money from a special interest to take an immoral position in
my opinion. And if that's If you as a lefty don't like that,
you should call him out for it. Okay. Legalized gambling in Texas.
Yeah. No. That
that is uh I don't care if Texans want gambling. If Texans wanted
to little kids, you shouldn't make it legal for Texans to [__]
three-year-olds. Okay. Casino gambling is not based. Gambling
is based. Casino gambling is not based. >> It's not about
left or right. It's about up and down and >> BLT is not
based. Okay. Not based.
>> Like stop doing the Eddie emote. Stop.
>> I have gotten the sense that more lefties um are starting
to catch on to Rico and support Tel Rico directly. I do get that
impression.
>> Right. And so uh you know in the context of that you
have this one kind of how many followers does Zachary Kirk have
here? It's 14,000. you know, not like a huge creator or whatever,
but >> and he comes out and he's like pro, you know, pro
uh Crockett. And then Taylor reposts him and says, "This guy's
a part of the the dark money slush fund." And then Hassan, I
don't know if he posted that after or before, and Hassan jumps
on it and adds the whole like Israeli element. It's their way
of like trying to discredit people. That's their that's his entire
mo. So like he has I think Hassan has figured out that he can
sort of condition his audience to take his lead. And if he tells
his audience, oh, you can't listen to this person, they dot dot
dot and there's like a thousand like fill in the blanks. Um,
and it's usually like a lot of times it's like a straw man argument
or you know he's done it to me a number of times where he'll
take a clip like with no context whatsoever and then pretend
as though you know I literally want to like court segregationist
into the party for example. I could take a gambling sponsor like
tomorrow
I could I could literally take a gambling sponsor tomorrow. They
give gambling sponsorships to anybody and my viewership and like
donations and everything is like crazy compared to other people
on on kick who have gambling sponsorships. Okay,
they would they would kill they would kill to give me a gambling
sponsorship. I'm not even joking. And I I truly believe it's
like immoral to do it now. The money the money would be crazy.
I just I feel like it's the funny thing is is I like gambling.
I have to I've got to go and do the um
No, I like gambling, Rhox. I still like gambling even after I
lost all that money on election day.
I still like gambling, but um I shouldn't.
Poly market is where we got to go. If we could get the poly market
sponsorship that would synergize with the stream that would be
amazing.
>> There's usually some kind of strongman in attack or
some kind of baseless smear, but like this is how they this is
how they operate. It's not new. Like this is not like a new >> You
bet on Kamla.
Even worse 050 despite a ton of early polling that led me to
believe that they were I bet on Kamla cuz I'm like yeah they're
but they're not like 10 to one.
They're like but they're not 10 to1. They're not like 20 to1.
They're but they're not 20 to1.
Bro, I would have made like I would have made like 30 grand if
I I'm pretty sure I would have made like 30 grand if I'd won
those bets. Maybe 50 grand.
instead, I lost like two grand. And by the way, Ethereum crashed
anyway. So hey, hey, we're fine.
The amount of money I lost is significantly lower than the amount
of money I w I I thought I lost. Okay, it's all fine. strategy
for propagandists to do. This has been like an established thing
that works for like hundreds of years. But yeah, that's what
>> yeah gambling works on a basis of basically taking a
certain person with a certain kind of personality and destroying
their life. That like gambling functions on two different customers.
People who are massively wealthy and can afford to just lose
tons of money and they do it for fun. And then people who are
not massively wealthy, can't afford to lose the money and give
up everything. Those are the two kinds of whales that all casinos
focus on. And that that second category of people who can't afford
it, destroying their lives, knowingly destroying their lives.
That's why I can't get behind gambling for the most part. Okay?
Like BLT stuff, uh casino stuff. I can't do it, man. It's just
it's super super super
up to me.
Uh because I know people who have lost everything, like literally
everything.
And you can lose and they they facilitate it. It's it's uh
it's bad. It's real bad. Can >> I ask questions? >> So,
do you have a problem if uh Hassan said something like this?
I hate it when influ when leftwing influencers or liberal influencers
repeat Israel talking points and act. >> Yes. And the scary
thing is
sorry, the scary thing is it's not just that it's like the most
addicting thing. The scary thing is is the people who are like
truly addicted to it, it like hits something on a lower level
of consciousness where you you actually for the people who are
like super addicted who can't stop, they actually aren't consciously
in control of their
like they actually it's like um there's a book I read about it
about habit forming and stuff. It's like the same way you know
how you'll like make a turn. Let's say you're like driving to
your your job and then your job relocates. you have to drive
a different way and you accidentally take the the wrong turn
to an old job. A lot of your personal thought process is actually
um subliminal, right? It's like it's like below the it's not
something you're consciously thinking about. And with gambling,
you can get like that dopamine hit is so addictive that you literally
aren't even conscious that you're like going back to start gambling
again. You you don't have higher function to control yourself
to stop doing it. Yeah, I know it's the unpredictability, but
you you will like go back to it over and over again. It's so
crazy because Zur gets for Israel with him saying that in the
same level of like disingenu >> Hold on, let me let me
back it up. >> Like hundreds of years, but >> I hate
it when in when leftwing influencers or liberal influencers repeat
Israel talking points and act as surrogates for Israel. Would
you have a problem with him saying that in the same level of
like disingenuousness and bad faith? Presumably not, right? If
you just said, you know, >> I have less of a problem with
that because that's less of a smear because at that point you're
just saying, "Oh, you agree with Israel." But as soon as you
start attaching like a financial incentive, oh, you're getting
paid to do Israeli talking points, that I think puts it in a
new tier, especially in the context of the language of genocide,
cuz his whole thing was like the libs won't call it a genocide,
live stream, holocaust, da da. As soon as you add like, oh, he's
being paid to essentially do genocide apologia, then I think
it takes it down to a level that is right down in the mud with
Alex Jones fake school shooting. No, I I think I actually don't
think it's worse.
I I think it's like a tiny
it's like a tiny I understand how you're getting there and okay
maybe maybe it's like slightly worse but it's like 90% of the
condemnation is in the genocide apology and then like 10% could
be that you're getting paid for it right he is saying he says
Han is paid by the CCP by the way I
>> I think this is very curious to me because he I don't
I haven't seen Hutch say that. Okay. I haven't seen Hutch say
But if he said that then I do think this is a crazy line for
him to go down.
Doesn't Hutch do genocide apology? I think Hutch is actually
pretty is quite a bit further left on the Israel Palestine thing
than people would ever give him credit for. I think he he like
actually has looked into it a decent amount. I think he probably
unknowingly does because a lot of his mutuals would be people
who would sort of not talk about it. But I think he goes further
than those people. I think so.
things situation. It's just like this, you know, he he there's
no depths that he will not sink to in his dishonesty. He will
he will use any smear that he thinks will give him some kind
of a tactical advantage. He has no fidelity to the truth at all.
Like he does not give a flying is what I'm trying to say. But
I don't know. We can uh that this isn't really what I wanted
to >> spend my time with. I looked into it. He literally
means watches loader box.
I think loader box is a pretty strong command of all the factual
information there.
And I think there are like ways I Yeah, you guys are never going
to see eye to eye with me on the litter box
>> You know what I'm talking about. >> I think it's
interesting that we can move on, but I >> uh Yes, but I'm
willing to be naive to that. Okay, Philip Oliver Holtz, I'm willing
to be naive to that. So, please I understand that connection.
I understand that this is essentially true. Okay, but I'm I'm
taking like uh 20% of what I could be taking to try to prevent
a little bit of harm. Okay, so chill. Thank you. just have like
a few other things like I'm about to give you like a different
scenario which isn't the same and there are ways that you could
distinguish it but for example um for the tenant media thing
right there are absolutely you know a closer connection between
Edward Gregorian I mean was essentally shell entity for Russian
government actors no doubt about that right no doubt about that
>> in that context if there were a clear money link where
it's like is like some sort of Israeli interest group has contributed
large amounts of money to the chorus fund um in that context
Let's try to make it more applicable. Or hell, let's even say
Israel is making some sort of illegal um far violating um
contribution or something or some other campaign contribution.
>> A whole video from Hutch about whether >> paid
propagandist, right? I mean, he said that about loner box. So,
I feel like we're totally justified in just flatly accusing him
of being paid. I think we should speak.
I uh I think it's always important in situations where you do
this to to literally always reiterate
what your
you should always
reiterate. You just you just blanked my mind because I'm I'm
rotating an apple in three dimensions right now.
Thank you, Ozel. I'm now I I just lost my thought process entirely.
Now I'm rotating an apple in three dimensions because I can do
that in my head. Okay. Uh it's always important to restate what
your principle is. No, I don't like lying about this. So I I
won't say that. Now in Han's worldview, you know, he's willing
to say this about other people without evidence. So I think it's
like kind of funny to say it about him without evidence, but
I don't actually believe it. But I don't think I don't think
Hutch is going to say that. Or maybe he is. I don't know. >> Think
about it like it's just an established fact cuz that's what he
did with Loner Box in Israel. I think we should give the same
energy. Uh let's go to the >> Yeah. I just I don't I personally
don't like that if you if you have a like if you have a principle
you don't go well actually you know these guys are Nazis so because
they're Nazis I think it's cool to just kill their entire like
their family every every part of the to try to genocide them
that's asminold level thinking
that's asminold tier thinking I don't like this about other people
so I kind of think it's cool to do the things that they do to
other people as well to them
I okay all right man all right man >> state media interview
at long last. 30 minute interview. >> Okay, whatever, whatever,
whatever, whatever, whatever. I still don't know. I still don't
know that he explicitly didn't do that, but it doesn't look good.
Okay, I'm I'm probably not going to watch that Hutch video. We've
got a lot of content today. We still haven't even gotten to the
Machar Hassan combo at all. So, we've got a lot of content. I
do want to get to all of it, so I'm not going to stop on that
right now. >> In itself, >> would you be okay with
them making these same kinds of comments? In other words, because
I don't think we would have like we don't really care about saying
Tim is just Russian propaganda. Temple now they maintain we weren't
influencing our content at all. This was hands off. Um is it
you don't have a problem with that? Correct. It's just like the
lack of or the presence of attenuation between the source of
funds and the lack of any evidence of government
>> It's I I think it's more the fact Pisco that the idea
that could be some kind of a paid Israeli propaganda effort was
utterly and completely annihilated within days of that reporting.
I feel like you would have had to have gone out of your >> No,
it wasn't. No, it wasn't. and you totally got your app blown
out by multiple people when they pointed out that like yeah they're
claiming this without evidence but also we don't know who they
fund like like literally it's not it's not proven that it's wrong
it's just they're saying that without evidence because you have
all the evidence that you won't show us it wasn't blown out none
of the narratives were blown out that's totally made up every
single thing that every single person other than Taylor Loren's
oh sorry other than I'll say the Israeli connection directly
those were all proven and Nothing that people said was like explicitly
disproven, I don't think. Right. There were claims made about
the contracts. Those are all proven.
You tried to twist that into they saying, "Oh, they're saying
like you you're you're actually prevented from ever talking to
a politician outside of chorus." Nope. Just the contract says
that. If you're going to say you don't enforce the contract,
you can put that on the record. Oh, no. You don't want to put
that on the record. It's just influencers coming out to say it.
Cuz if you put that on the record, you'd probably be violating
campaign finance law. Oh, interesting. Very cool. Very neat.
your way to not see the the many receipts that creators were
dropping in the days that followed that article. Examples of
chorus creators that were not only outspoken about Israel, but
they were using the same language. Like they were using the same
really strong harsh language for people like Chuck Schumer. They
were calling it a genocide. These kinds of things like you had
to have gone out of your way to miss those things. But the whole
point is like these creators that have this influence, this is
a this is they will head off that
publish all of the creators in the incubator program and just
audit their positions. Like I I'll just say, okay, I have an
a-olitical pack hutch. We've got like four purple state Democrats
in it. We have 75 people, four purple state Democrats who talk
about, you know, a lot of the things you do. They call MAGA,
they call Trump a fascist. But actually, the other 71 all explicitly
post like pure Democrat hate and pure Hassan dick sucking or
sorry not Hassan Trump dick tucking. Okay. Am I actually helping
your cause? Am I actually a positive force in the world for the
things you like? No, I'm not.
I'm not. Okay. As come on, man. Kind of stuff by discrediting
these people in the way that I just told you about. So, it kind
of makes perfect sense that a lot of people in Hassan's audience
didn't see those receipts because he and all that that whole
ecosystem, they just like smear and lie to everybody. And as
soon as you tell your audience, oh, this person is being paid
to apologize to do apology for like a genocide, then of course
it makes sense that they didn't see any of those receipts because
in their minds, they're like, "Oh, this guy's a gen Why would
I why would I even watch a 10-second clip when they're doing
genocide apologia?" And so, like, the whole thing, Pisco, the
whole thing is intentionally dishonest. That's my >> From
a from a Marxist Leninist who wants to destroy democracy and
all capital owners, right? Like Hassan is a Marxist Leninist
who wants to all capital owners and destroy society,
right? Why would you have to even watch clips from him? Why would
you have to watch clips, Pisco? Why would you defend Hassan at
all? Why would you show him charity? He don't you know he's a
Marxist Leninist who wants to destroy democracy. He hates liberal
democracy. Don't you know that? >> They know they're lying.
It's a It is a >> That's certainly not the same thing.
That's certainly not similar at all. It's not the same. It's
not It's way different when Hutch does it, guys. Because there's
a clip from the DP program four years ago, five years ago where
Hassan says he has to hide his power level. So actually we know
that that's true.
Just so we're all aware. >> Conscious deliberate effort
that they're doing to try to discredit people that they think
represent a threat to their populist left movement. That's what
this is all about. That's that's what I >> Got it. I I
think that it runs the gamut um between people who are intentionally
deceptive and making false implications or leaving enough question
marks um and people who genuinely either are hoodwinks that there's
some additional evidence of like Israeli influence or Israeli
aligned influence in some of these creators. Um so I'm not sure
I'm going to label that all these people whoever these denominator
is are all lying. I don't think I can justify that claim. Um
but surely I I think that you have a responsibility if you accuse
people of being paid Israel shills or something like that that
there should be substantiation. I have less of a >> Pretty
serious allegation. >> It's I think it's a super serious
allegation. That's one of the reasons why I think disclosure
is important. just because um >> okay now I do think that
I do think it would be funny if if Pisco brought up the funding
and stuff. I need to use the bathroom, get some water. I'm getting
ready to switch over to the son Mockler combo after this. We'll
watch a little more of this. Somebody says uh it gets brought
up the Marxist Leninist stuff gets brought up. I'd be interested
in that if there's a time stamp for it. I just don't know. There's
no transcript yet so I can't search for it. If you guys want
to find that I'll I'll switch to that and then we'll go into
the Hassan Machler stuff. And then we've got a bunch of other
drama, bunch of awesome drama. You know, the Nicholas Yoro Chud
stuff that's all kicking off. I've heard Nicholas has made additional
statements since. Okay, we've got some Nicholas Yoro reaction
to the Chud stuff, which should be very interesting. We've got
the Chud video right here. The Dioro video. Total coward. Okay,
they they gave him like a piggy nose in the thumbnail. DK gave
him a piggy nose in the thumbnail and put oink oink in the thumbnail.
So, that should be pretty interesting, too. Okay. Classic chorus
drama throwback. David Pacman forgets how to pronounce Apac.
This was very funny. Hold on before I walk away. >> Creators
in the first 48 hours took the Wired story and expanded it with
even more outrageous claims suggesting that it's APAC or IPAC.
I I don't even know how it's pronounced. APAC. IPAC. Guys, I'm
so far away from Israeli money. I don't even know how to say
Apac. I'm so I've never heard of this. Political content creator
for like a decade, by the way. Political content creator for
like a decade. How do you say it? IPAC. Apac. Apac. IPAC.
With DPAC, he might be trolling. I don't accept those arguments.
It's goofy. You're It's goofy. Okay. He could be trolling, but
that's technically true for literally everybody. I don't like
that. People used to do that with Miskip in here, too. Um, actually,
the thing he said might be trolling. No. No, it's not.
Unless he wants to say it. Unless he wants to say, "Oh, I was
just making that up. Obviously, I know about Apac.
Anyway, it's fine. It's fine. Goofy is >> I'm gonna hit
play on this. I I have to use the bathroom. Get some water. I'll
be right back. Okay. Two seconds. Well, more like two minutes,
but not stealing his cont.
But also because I think at times it can inoculate you um by
by showing that you're up front about, you know, that you're
getting money from this particular place. And almost like the
the lack of disclosure on that, I think it hurts a lot of these
creators. Um that said, it might also put a target on their back
for like bad faith actors or whatever. Um that said like thing
is people can draw conclusions based on money and politics money
in this or that a source of money everyone does it. Um and I
would absolutely take issue and do take issue with people turning
chorus into something that it's not when there's no evidence
of it. That's why retrial coh that's why I take the stance that
I do. That's why generally I'm supportive of course existing.
Um that said like if it's funded in a particular way there going
to be criticisms of it that way and not all the criticisms are
bad faith in my opinion. >> I don't know. I feel like you're
kind of doing gymnastics here buddy. >> What what's gymnastics?
What did I say that's unreasonable?
So, I just learned about a man Bailey and I feel like this is
like a man Bailey where like the Bailey would be, you know, uh
like trying to defend, not that you made this argument, like
trying to defend the idea that you can you should you can just
like casually accuse people of doing Israel propaganda, but it
feels like you retreated to a more defensible position of like,
well, you know, there are some issues with um the idea of like
any kind of dark moneying and disclosure. Therefore, I can understand
like why people have those complaints, but I'm not talking about
that. I mean, I understand that that's like
I I somewhat agree with you. I I think that disclosure is good.
So, for example, 16, 15 years ago when major companies first
started sponsoring YouTubers, it was kind of like the wild wild
west because the FCC wasn't really monitoring that space in the
same way. And so, I would get contracts for sponsored content
and it would specifically say in the contract, don't
>> So, like they these advertisers knew that at least for
the time being, the FCC was not paying attention to that space
because it was like burgeoning and new and there were no you
know there weren't there weren't the same kind of regulatory
eyes on that space. And so I would I would send the contracts
back and say no, I insist that I'm going to tell my audience
that this is paid like it feels dishonest. So I I do understand
that that is a like if that is a defensible argument, I agree
with that argument. I think disclosure would be better. I'm also
sympathetic to the idea that um these creators could be targeted
by this um psychopathic
online uh populist left who are completely deranged and unhinged.
And so I'm a little bit sympathetic to that as well. But that's
not I'm not talking about these kinds of like reasonable critiques
of the structure and the non-disclosure. Like okay, that's fine.
And I agree with you on some of that or maybe even most of that.
I'm not talking about that. I'm talking about the idea of if
a if a creator shows up on your feed and you just want to discredit
them in the eyes of your audience, you just baselessly accuse
them of being paid by Israel to do propaganda. Like that is so
far removed from the critique that you you just gave. >> He
gets paid by somebody he gets paid by a pack that's closely aligned
to the Democratic party and does Israel propaganda. But those
things are totally distinct, guys. Okay? Those are totally distinct.
Totally distinguishable. Okay? Not the same thing. He is an Israel
shill and he is a chorus paid creator, but those two are not
connected.
Say it, Hassan. Say it, >> Dave. You know, I >> By
the way, I sounded like I was being sarcastic there. That is
almost certainly the case. Okay, that this guy's I I don't think
I haven't seen evidence that Chorus is like overtly pushing people
to support Israel or something, right? My suspicion would be
that because they are more aligned with the Democratic Party
that they would pay more creators who support Israel than don't.
That would be my suspicion. Okay, that would be my suspicion.
That's it. >> Don't have any intention of doing a Mont
Bailey or anything like that. >> Yo, Dickers, thank you
for the raid.
>> would condemn reflexively or knowingly, maliciously
uh accusing people of taking money without any evidence. Uh I
hope that you didn't get the impression that that um I would
think that that's like good or okay or justifiable or whatever.
All I'm saying is like I think what you're asking for was like
a broader set of condemnations around quoteunquote like these
people and their different problems. And I just like some people
are lying for sure. Some people are delusional. Um some people
have what I take to being good faith criticism even if I don't
agree with it. And that's all I'm saying is that all criticism
of course is not illegitimate. Some of it is. And when you point
to specific examples by specific people, 100% I'm I'm there.
But like for example, if Apac gave money directly to this fund
or whatever or to creators, I don't think we have a problem with
them like they're paid Israel shills, right? Even if they're
like but no Apac doesn't influence what I do. Um, now in this
case, I think the evidence is not strong that there's any uh
sort of content regulation, any kind of uh specific ideological
other than pro-democrat that is like tailoring content of any
kind. But um I just think that there's like Okay, I didn't see
if anybody posted the link I was asking for. I didn't see that.
If you did, let me know. If not, I think we will keep going.
Oh, I saw this. Even Dioro is joining in on the hutch dunking.
What?
Dude, I'm sorry. I'm starting to get angry about his derangement
syndrome, too. This >> Oh, is it gonna be the bungee tweet?
Is he pulling up the bungee tweet? >> This is like This
is actually one of the most insane clips I've ever seen in my
life. I Yeah, >> this is uh
uh How could we What is this comparable to? I'm not totally sure,
man. It's It's very funny.
I I feel like we are We're like three months away from Nicholas
Yorio going like, "Guys, I just think Ethan Klein's being a little
unreasonable." like suing those people. It was really up for
him to sue those people. Actually, guys, I just think Ethan Klein
was being like a little unreasonable. Don't we all agree that
like maybe he's not the worst, but like maybe Ethan Klein's like
a little unreasonable, guys. Don't you think so? Don't you think?
I'm calling you out. This is absolutely ridiculous. >> Tell
me what is Jeffrey Epstein's policy
Dude, you don't need That's a >> Wait, I thought we I thought
we didn't do politics on the Nicholas Yoro stream. I thought
we didn't talk about politics on the Nicholas Yoro stream. Guys,
this is just like a Fortnite commentary stream. Oh, wait. There's
a political position I can criticize. Oh, I'll do that right
away.
Good one. Good one. >> Fair question, isn't it? >> This
is every This is every internet >> I I don't know politics.
I just I know I could criticize that. Shut up. >> By the
way, it's all this. It's all this every internet debate that
occurs in current day is just clippable like this >> kind
of person. I don't know anything about his politics. >> Don't
talk about politics. Don't talk about anything, guys. Just just
like only give opinions that nobody could ever make fun of you
for ever, no matter what. Be a totally amorphous blob both physically
and mentally like me and then you'll be happy. No, we won't.
We won't actually. People like having opinions. People like talking
about things. Stop giving the most soulless takes on planet Earth,
you worthless shill. Thank you. The reason why I would not necessarily
disqualify Jeffrey Epstein electorally
is because first we would have to establish if he supports liberal
>> The longer this clip goes on, the worse it sounds. To
be clear, >> I'm the crazy one who's like, uh, I don't
know what's Jeffrey Epstein. By the way,
while I disagree with Hutch's position in so many ways,
if somebody were to articulate his position
who's smarter than Hutch, okay, it's basically saying that while
we retain a democracy, we have the ability to fix the wrongs
that we've committed. So, while I hate Jeffrey Epstein and everything
he stood for, if he were to support liberal democracy and not
undo it, then we could fix the problems hypothetically
that there's always a potential future solution so long as you're
still democ democratic. Okay, that's what Hutch's position is.
That's what he's trying to say, which is not even it's not stupid.
I think probably you just say like, oh, abs is why
you can have some moral criteria as well.
>> Policy position when he when he glorifies the current
>> Pisco articulated. Yeah. No, I I didn't listen to Pisco
do it. I could just do it myself. It's literally just you can
always fix it. It's things are always fixable. This framework
is the best framework. It's like built every liberal democracy
that's there.
Yeah. It's it's super easy to understand what Hutch's position
is. I just I hate the idea that like Well, it's super easy. It's
super easy to understand the position Hutch is trying to articulate
based on what he's seen from somebody else. So just Nicholas,
I get super annoyed with Nicholas's anti-intellectualism.
This is always this is everything. Every conversation about this
is is like this. It's just always goofy. No, sometimes people
get hyperbolic with examples because getting hyperbolic with
examples allows you to to like define lines very easily.
That's not a bad mental exercise. It's a good mental exercise.
You shouldn't freak the out when people do it. This is Everybody
thinks this, by the way. Everybody intelligent thinks what I
think on this that you should never ever ever like hear something
that offends you, that upsets you, that's like weird or something
and go, "Oh, I don't want to listen anymore." That's like the
opposite of what you should do. That's that's actually like the
height of the problem with the entire woke movement is that they
would have thought terminating responses to certain statements
or certain feelings, certain like points people would make and
they'd freak the out.
Are you really siding with Hutch on this? I'm siding against
I don't side with Hutch. explained my criticisms of Hutch.
I'm saying I hate anti-intellectualism even more than I hate
what Hutch says on a live stream.
If you think I'm just agreeing with Hutch here, I'm saying this
is what Hutch's point should be. This is the point he should
articulate. It's what he's trying to say with the Epstein thing,
right? I think that on top of that, you can have a principal
commitment to I'm not going to show for any candidate who violates
certain things. running a mass
extortion ring probably at the top of that list that sort of
prevents him from being a candidate I would ever support.
But then if you literally have like Epstein the guy who's like
you for some reason believe is going to keep democracy going
and then you've got like Mecca Hitler on the other side. Okay,
Elon Musk actually brought Mecca Hitler Mecca Hitler to life.
Okay, on the other side of the ballot, then probably you vote
for Jeffrey Epstein. I guess
>> you know Chinese Communist Party. I I I absolutely hate
this. I hate this so much. It's like there is like 10% irony
in here and like 90% Ah,
those weren't the choices. Yeah, the Hassan versus Epstein choices
pretty easily, Hassan, I think. But you have to have reasonable
positions. It's
the whole Epstein hypothetical. I just don't I think being like
uh being like, "Oh, it's just so weird to talk about this is
goofy.
You stop thinking about it." Mecha Hitler is kind of cool, though.
Okay. All right, we continue. We're going to keep going with
content here. God,
I'm just saying the idea that you just shut down and you go,
"Oh, every every debate is like this." It's like, no, these there
are conversations here that are fruitful. Just it's anti-intellectualism
is very annoying to
Um, okay. No, no, you're not scoping me into that. No, thank
you. I think we're basically done with this, right? >> Context
and different criticisms. And I'm not sure what I'm signing up
to when you ask me to condemn certain things or call them lies.
I'm happy to do that for specific critiques, but I don't think
that all critiques of chorus are like that. I don't think that's
unreasonable. Or Bailey, >> I guess u I guess this feels
like it is relevant in the context of the larger conversation
that I've been having with like you. >> I just I get annoyed
at Hutch because he can't even articulate what should be his
position correctly. He can't even like I have to and I noticed
Pisco do it as well. They're like trying to articulate his position
back to him without telling him this is actually your position
all the time. Consistently
just consistently being like well if you're saying like this
thing that you should actually be
>> do a lot in the last 9 months or however long it's been
>> where I go dump something down for H. Okay. I just wanted
the other clip but if we don't have it we don't have it. Give
me a second. I think somebody said it was it was about maybe
the funding thing or somebody pointed this out.
Um the Oh, somebody asked earlier if the chorus people have NDAs.
They do have NDAs, but they don't I think they basically say
they don't, you know, hit people for violating them.
>> Angry about his song. >> Wait, this is not the
right clip. What was I looking at? I was trying to look at something
else. Let's go dumb something down. Pro. This is what I meant
to click on.
>> You're going to have to dumb that way down for me. >> So,
do you >> My brain,
>> is not the best brain. Okay. You got to talk to me like
a sixth grader sometimes. Pisco, I I'm trying to uh I'm sorry
if I'm too like verbose. You spend >> your lawyerly words.
Like we get it. You have a degree, bro. It's [__]
cool. That's great. Can we move on? You passed the bar. Okay,
fine. Great. >> You spend a lot of time criticizing
lefties who are like more or at least claim some kind of position
in quote unquote our coalition, our camp on the left. and you
do so
um I thought on the rationale that well I want to grab their
audience and it's actually like not an inefficient use of my
time to spend focusing on these people because it's um it's a
huge area where Democrats can get gains is by suppressing this
kind of internal or at least more internal um opposition which
is functionally oppositionary but like from within our house
right and isn't that like the same logic of someone who would
say, "Well, I spent all my time criticizing Democrats on Israel
or on trans issues because I know that it's like uh you know,
it's better to get my house in order, similar to how you would
say it for the lefties." Do you see what I'm saying?
>> Yes. But I I don't think it's the same thing because
I'm right and they're
>> Oh, I you might be right and they might be wrong. I
just mean like in terms of the incentive structure, like
it doesn't mean they're necessarily bad faith and they don't
believe what they believe. It could just be like they tactically
see um it like a waste of their time and I don't necessarily
agree with that but similar to how you might think well there
it's actually efficient for me you know there's plenty of room
for people to be self-critical when it comes to lefties they
might think the same thing about like the libs or whatever or
the establishment people now we might disagree with them but
uh it doesn't necessarily speak to their good or bad